Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu Forschergeist, dem Podcast des Stifterverbands für die deutsche Wissenschaft. Mein Name ist Tim Pritlove und ich begrüße alle hier zur Ausgabe Nummer 43 unserer Gesprächsserie über das Lernen, über die Bildung, über die Wissenschaft und alle anderen Fragen, die sich mittelbar daraus ergeben. Und ja in letzter Zeit haben wir uns viel mit dem Lernen beschäftigt und wollen das auch in der heutigen Sendung nochmal fortführen. Und dazu hat mich der Weg geführt nach Hamburg, konkreter ins Landesinstitut für Lehrerbildung und Schulentwicklung in Hamburg. Und ich begrüße meine Gesprächspartnerin Lisa Rosa, schönen guten Tag.
Hallo guten Tag Tim.
Lisa, ja ich habe es gerade gesagt, Landesinstitut für Lehrerbildung und Schulentwicklung Hamburg. Kompliziertes Wort, was steckt da kurz gesagt dahinter?
Naja bei uns werden die Lehrer ausgebildet und weitergebildet. Also wir haben Referendare in der zweiten Ausbildungsphase und wir haben altgediente Lehrer, die kommen bei uns zur Fortbildung. Hamburg hat verpflichtend 30 Stunden Fortbildung für jeden Lehrer pro Jahr in der Arbeitszeit. Und dann kommt der Teil Schulentwicklung. Wir beschäftigen uns auch damit, Unterricht und Schulqualität zu sichern, aber auch weiterzuentwickeln.
Also auch zu messen?
Wenn man da was messen kann. Also beurteilen sicher.
Ich weiß nicht, ob man da was messen kann, kann man?
Manche Sachen kann man vielleicht messen, aber die meisten Sachen oder sehr viele Sachen kann man nicht messen. Und die Verwechslung oder In-Eins-Setzung von etwas evaluieren, um es beurteilen zu können mit messen, das ist überall in der Gesellschaft. Alles wird gemessen und mathematisiert, das hat mit der Wirtschaft natürlich zu tun. Das ist aber in komplexen Systemen gar nicht möglich, alles zu messen. Also Lebensqualität, wie will man das messen? Man kann es nicht messen, man kann es aus den Aussagen derer, die sich dazu äußern, deren Lebensqualität beurteilt werden soll, entnehmen, wie sie selber … also das ist unheimlich viel Gefühl und subjektiver Faktor dabei. Einige Dinge kann man natürlich messen. Zum Beispiel mit wie viel Einkommen jemand auskommen muss und wie groß wohl seine Teilhabemöglichkeit an der Gesellschaft ist. Das kann man sicher in Geld messen.
Aber wie er sich dabei fühlt und was er für Möglichkeiten findet, trotzdem noch ein halbwegs sinnvolles Leben zu führen, das lässt sich nicht mehr messen. Und genauso ist es mit Lernen und Lernergebnissen und Schulqualität oft auch.
Man kann beobachten und Gewichten, aber man hat nicht für alles ein Einheitssystem.
So ist es.
An dem man es ausrichten kann. Dann würde ich gerne mal mit dir selber einsteigen. Du bist selber lange lange Zeit auch Lehrerin gewesen an einer Gesamtschule und am Gymnasium, wenn ich das richtig sehe, in Berlin und Hamburg.
Ja.
War das so der Wunschberuf von vornherein? Was motiviert einen, diesen Weg einzuschlagen?
Also geboren bin ich sicher nicht mit dem Wunsch, Lehrer zu werden. Aber als ich dann mich durch verschiedene Studienfächer durchgearbeitet hatte, habe ich überlegt, was mach ich jetzt damit? Und dann war die Option, ich könnte an der Universität bleiben und Wissenschaftler werden. Und dann hätte ich wieder gesessen und gelesen und Arbeiten geschrieben. Das war ja bisher mein Leben gewesen und ich wollte aber mal was machen. Ich wollte mal was in der Praxis machen. Lesen und schreiben ist natürlich auch eine Art Praxis, aber ich wollte das, weil es sich ja nicht um freie Wissenschaft, sondern um pädagogischen Wissenschaft handelte, mit der ich mich beschäftigt habe, wollte ich das natürlich alles mal in der Praxis auch anwenden. Und das war auch richtig so. weil ich glaube, ohne dass man selber in der Praxis gedient hat, kann man auch über Pädagogik nicht wirklich sinnvolle theoretische Aussagen treffen.
Was für Studienfächer waren denn das?
Ohje ich habe angefangen mit Geschichte und Politik. Dann habe ich lange Russisch studiert. Bin durch verschiedene Prüfungen auch gegangen. Altgriechenslawisch und was da alles ist. Und kurz vor dem entscheidenen Endexamen habe ich gesagt, ach nein ich bin noch nicht fertig. Das war so die Zeit, wo man noch das Studium genießen konnte. Und habe dann noch Musik studiert. Und das hat auch den Ausschlag gegeben für den dann Wunschberuf eines Lehrers von mir. Weil Musiklehrer wurden gesucht. Politiklehrer und Geschichtslehrer damit konnte man Ende der 70er Jahre, 80er Jahre Anfang, als ich fertig wurde, die Straße pflastern. Musiklehrer da hatte ich echt privilegierte Einstellungen. Mir sind die Stellen mehr oder weniger nachgeworfen worden. Und das macht natürlich die Entscheidung dafür dann auch einfacher. Also da spielen eine Menge Dinge mit.
Aber trotzdem war doch so Geschichte tatsächlich auch ein Teil deiner Arbeit?
Ja Geschichte ist eigentlich das Fach meines Lebens. Ich war lange Musiklehrerin, 20 Jahre, habe auch viel Spaß dabei gehabt, aber jetzt habe ich alle Instrumente verkauft und mache auch keine Musik mehr. Während Geschichte bleibt. Weil Geschichte ist auch eine Erkenntnisweise, die man eigentlich überall braucht. Das ist nicht nur Geschichte so archivarisch. Man will wissen, wie es früher gewesen ist und da zieht man irgendwelche Steine raus, in die was reingekloppt ist oder andere Sorten von Quellen, sondern man fragt ja immer aus der Gegenwart. Was kann ich an der Entwicklung der Menschheit, und vor allen Dingen an der Entwicklung seiner Gesellschaftlichkeit, erkennen, was mir heute nutzt in meinem heutigen gesellschaftlichen Leben. Und da wir in so turbulenten Zeiten leben, muss man ja politisch denken, wenn man irgendwie mitmischen will und sich nicht alles aufs Auge drücken lassen will und da ist ein historischer Blick richtig.
Weil da kann man eine Menge Dinge doch draus lernen, die fürs heutige Verhalten interessant sind.
Also auch die Schüler können daraus lernen?
Ja sicher, jeder.
Inwiefern war das jetzt im Zentrum deiner Arbeit?
Ja ich weiß ja nicht, was du für einen Geschichtsunterricht hattest?
Ja, ich auch nicht. Ich hatte einen grottenschlimmen Geschichtsunterricht und habe auch in der Ausbildung keinen guten Geschichtsunterricht gelernt. Eben nicht den Blick von heute. Also Geschichte und Politik gehören für mich zusammen. Nicht historische Politikwissenschaft guckt nicht richtig. Also es gibt übrigens von Marx den Spruch, die Geschichte ist die Mutter aller Wissenschaften. Und das hat er insofern gemeint, dass alles ja eine Herkunft hat. Also alles ist Gewordenes. Das ist eine Prämisse, die nicht jeder teilt. Es gibt konstruktivistisch, subjektivistisch natürlich auch andere Vorstellungen davon, wie die Welt funktioniert. Aber für mich ist das eine klar Setzung, alles hat sich entwickelt. Jeder Physiker würde dem zustimmen, weil anders ist die Weltraumphysik auch zum Beispiel gar nicht erklärbar, und dasselbe gilt natürlich für die Gesellschaft.
Keinen guten.
Und es gibt nichts, was von Anfang an da war. Aber alles hat sich aus etwas raus entwickelt, was vor ihm war. Dabei muss man sicher nicht fragen, was war eigentlich der Urknall, der Anfang, sondern man muss sich immer weiter zurückfragen aus dem Heute, was war eigentlich davor konkret, ganz konkret jetzt politisch? Haben wir dieses ökonomische System, mit dem wir leben müssen, eigentlich schon immer gehabt? Und wieso ist das so geworden, wie es geworden ist? Und wenn man diesen jetzt sehr einfach ausgedrückten historischen Blick generell hat an alles, woran man rangeht, dann kann es einem gar nicht passieren, dass man glaubt, das wäre das Ende der Geschichte und der Kapitalismus wäre für immer. Die nächste Frage, die sich dann stellt, ist, was sind denn eigentlich die Bedingungen, unter denen sich Gesellschaft verändert? Hatten wir denn schon mal gesellschaftliche Veränderungen? Dann guckt man in frühere Epochen, wo sich die eine Gesellschaft zu einer anderen verändert hat.
Und an diese Veränderungs- oder Übergangsgesellschaft, also dieser Übergangszeit, kann man bestimmte Bedingungen wissenschaftlich erkennen, die möglicherweise verallgemeinerbar sind, also die uns in unserer Übergangszeit zu einer neuen Gesellschaft auch vor die Füße geworden werden und mit denen wir umgehen müssen. Wenn wir die aber nicht kennen, dann fahren wir ja Blindflug. Und wenn wir nicht Blindflug fliegen wollen, sondern orientiert und mit dem Wissen, was möglich ist über Entwicklung der Gesellschaft, an Gesellschaftsveränderung ranzugehen, - jetzt habe ich vergessen, wie ich den Satz angefangen habe. - Also wir müssen wissen, was wir tun.
Höre ich da auch so ein Plädoyer raus, quasi Geschichte generell von vorne nach hinten aufzuzäumen, dass man eigentlich eher von der Gegenwart ausgehen sollte nach hinten?
Ja.
Ich habe so Geschichtsunterricht auch noch so ein bisschen in Erinnerung, da hat man irgendwelche Könige nummeriert. Und ich habe mich schon immer so gefragt, kommen wir denn eigentlich irgendwann nochmal in dieser Schulzeit ins Jetzt. Antwort, nein. Irgendwie fehlten dann am Schluss so gefühlt 100 Jahre, wo ich mich auch fragte, waren das jetzt die uninteressantestes 100 Jahre, nachdem wir die ganzen Könige durchmarschiert haben. Das war auf jeden Fall auch eine Unterlassung. Aber grundsätzlich von jetzt zurückgehen?
Ja, und das weiß man in der Geschichtsdidaktik eigentlich schon seit den frühen 80er Jahren. Jörn Rüsen hat die moderne Geschichtsdidaktik begründet sage ich mal so. Und den habe ich als jungen Mann im Studium auch kennengelernt. Diesen Blick, dass man eigentlich sinnvoll die Fragen an die Geschichte nur stellen kann, und Wissenschaft muss ja immer Fragen an seinen Gegenstand stellen, sonst kann sie nichts rauskriegen, kann man nur von heute aus. Wir können nicht – also das kann man als Gedankenexperiment machen, - von gestern aus fragen, aber weil wir nicht genau wissen, wie die Menschen gestern waren, weil die nicht mehr da sind und nur ihre Zeugnisse hinterlassen haben. Also Geschichtsunterricht sagen wir mal so ist der Geschichtsdidaktik und der Geschichtswissenschaft sicher um mehrere Jahrzehnte hinterher. Und das ist eigentlich eine Katastrophe.
Wie ging es dann für dich selber weiter? Also die 20 Jahre waren dann wann abgeschlossen?
2005 bin ich hier ans Institut gekommen und habe Lehrerausbildung bzw. Unterrichtsentwicklung angefangen und im Fachbereich Gesellschaft. Dadurch habe ich auch berufliche Verbindungen zur Musik gar nicht mehr entwickelt, weiter entwickelt. Aber das wäre mir auch zu viel geworden. Und da eben Fach Gesellschaftswissenschaften, hier im Referat Gesellschaftswissenschaften in der Lehrerfortbildung fühle ich mich auch super richtig seit 12 Jahren. Und ich bin vor allen Dingen beschäftigt mit Projektdidaktik und Demokratiepädagogik. Ich bin nicht ganz zufrieden mit dem Namen, aber soll es gewesen sein. Das ist eine andere Richtung von politischer Bildung. Da gibt es auch verschiedene sich nicht immer vertragende Richtungen. Und ich habe dann selber noch drauf gesetzt eigentlich mein Arbeitsgebiet lernen in der Wissensgesellschaft.
Weil ich mich vor allen Dingen intensiv mit Lerntheorien beschäftigt habe. Projektlernen muss ja mit moderner Lerntheorie irgendwie in Vereinbarung sein. Und da ich seit 2005 selber ein Weblog führe, damals, als ich angefangen habe, war das eigentlich noch gar nicht bekannt, was das eigentlich ist. Und sehr gemerkt habe, dass das etwas ist, was das Lernen revolutionieren könnte.
Was das Weblog selber oder das Netz als solches?
Ja. Also das Netz als solches sowieso, darüber reden wir ja noch, aber auch das Bloggen vor allen Dingen noch ganz eng angebunden jetzt an das Lernen in der Schule. Weil das eine Möglichkeit ist, zu externalisieren, was zu produzieren, sein Wissen darzustellen und dann mit anderen zu diskutieren, etwas was in der Schule schwer zu bewerkstelligen ist. Weil wir ja nicht einen Lehrer und einen Schüler gegenüber haben, sondern in großen Gruppen lernen. Ich weiß nicht, ob du mal durchgerechnet hast, wie oft ein Schüler eigentlich drankommen kann im Unterricht, selbstständig etwas zu sagen, wenn der Unterricht 45 Minuten dauert und 30 Kinder in der Klasse sitzen und die Hälfte der Zeit der Lehrer mit seinen Aussagen benutzt und dann noch 10 Minuten damit verwendet werden, Ruhe in der Klasse herzustellen, da kommt also …
Nicht viel bei raus.
Da kommt der Schüler selber nicht viel zum Sprechen. Also gibt es dann nur noch die Möglichkeit, wenn er sich externalisiert, also das gehört zum Lernen dazu, ich spreche jetzt auf so einer lerntheoretischen Ebene, man muss, um was zu lernen, verinnerlichen, man muss veräußerlichen. Das heißt sein Verständnis von einer Sache darlegen können, um es dann mit anderen zu besprechen und zu diskutieren und womöglich zu korrigieren, was man falsch verstanden hat. Ganz eigentlich klarer Vorgang, den jeder verstehen kann. Und wie ist der organisiert? In der Schule auf eine bestimmte Weise. Und wenn man in großen Gruppen lernt, dann ist das Dialogische, wo der Schüler sprechen kann und wo meinetwegen sogar eine richtige Diskussion entsteht und das sich externalisieren eben schwer zu organisieren im Klassenunterricht, der stofforientiert ist und nicht von den Schülern ausgeht.
Das hießt der Blog war ein Versuch, einen Dialog herzustellen?
Das habe ich überhaupt erst entdeckt. Also es war sehr witzig, ich habe das Bloggen entdeckt, weil ich eigentlich selber gerne schreibe und weil ich zum ersten Mal, das war mein Einstellungsaufsatz sozusagen, um hier am Institut arbeiten zu können, einen pädagogischen Aufsatz geschrieben habe, der wurde in einer erziehungswissenschaftlichen Zeitschrift veröffentlicht und das war meine erste Veröffentlichung. Und da habe ich aber auch gesehen, wie schwer das ist, die eigenen Gedanken zu veröffentlichen und zu diskutieren. Dieser Aufsatz wurde eigentlich nicht diskutiert, weswegen ich gesagt habe, wozu ist der dann veröffentlicht, wenn ich mit niemandem darüber reden kann? Und außerdem war der Verlag davor. Ich habe diese Veröffentlichung nur gekriegt, weil der Direktor sich drum gekümmert hat, dass das veröffentlicht wird. Auf meinen blanken Namen hin wäre der Aufsatz und der Verlag gar nicht zusammen gekommen.
Und dann habe ich, ich weiß nicht, ob das zufällig war oder auch gesucht, eben das Bloggen entdeckt und habe gesehen, wie einfach das ist. Man kann alles veröffentlichen selber, da ist keine Autorität, keine Instanz mehr dazwischen und vor allen Dingen, das ist ja das Besondere, wenn man es gut anstellt und weiß, wie man mögliche Antworter und Gesprächspartner an Land zieht, kann man da auch seine Sachen diskutiert kriegen. Und möglicherweise auch Kontroversen und daran kann man lernen. Und das habe ich getan. Also wenn ich mir meine Blogeinträge von vor 12 Jahren angucke, dann greife ich mir an den Kopf und denke, so hast du damals gedacht, ach du liebe Zeit. Also ich kann meine eigene Lernentwicklung nachvollziehen an – was weiß ich – 260 Blogbeiträgen.
Ja ich geh auch immer wieder in so einen Schockmodus, wenn ich mir meine alten Sendungen anhöre. Aber immerhin, solange man noch Fortschritt spüren kann, ist ja noch nichts verloren. Ja also zusammengefasst, Schule war dir wichtig, der Geschichtskontext war dir wichtig, aber auch das Aufnehmen der technologischen Entwicklung und der sich daraus ergebenen Möglichkeiten. Das war ja hier auch schon oft Thema und das soll auch definitiv ein Schwerpunkt hier unseres Gesprächs darstellen. Ich würde jetzt allerdings doch mal zunächst einmal ein Verständnis schaffen wollen, wo ich so den Eindruck habe, dass das nicht jeder hat, mich eingeschlossen, Schule ist ja so das, wo jeder mal war und dann hat man so diese Erinnerung, wie das halt früher mal war, aber was sich seitdem dann getan hat weiß man nicht.
Dann hat man irgendwann vielleicht selber Kinder, die man in die Schule schickt, hat eine gewisse Erwartung, erkennt manches wieder, vielleicht auch schon wieder zu viel. Ist aber natürlich jetzt auch nicht so direkt damit verbunden, weil man geht ja nicht selber hin, sondern man beobachtet quasi nur die Folgen davon und ist vielleicht ab und zu mal beim Elternabend, was auch eine sehr geringe Involviertheit darstellt. Wie hat sich das Lernen in der Schule entwickelt? Also um mal ein bisschen zu versuchen, den Status quo herauszuarbeiten, wie weit müsste man jetzt überhaupt zurückblicken, um überhaupt erst mal festzustellen, da hat sich eine Struktur herausgebildet, die mit der heutigen Struktur zumindest verwandt ist?
Also wenn man aufs Lernen guckt alleine, dann muss man aufpassen, dass man eben nicht die Struktur dabei verliert, weil die findet ja in einem organisierten System statt. Ich lieb die Systemtheorie, weil die vor allen Dingen erklären kann, warum egal was die Personen wollen, sich trotzdem etwas anderes durchsetzt. Das ist ja die Erfahrung, die viele machen. Und das kann man nur verstehen, warum das so sein kann, dass die Personen nicht Herr der Lage sind, wenn man das System, also was du Struktur nennst und die Personen auseinandernimmt und unterscheiden kann. Was die Schüler lernen können, hat auch mit den Systemnischen Bedingungen zu tun. Und was sie lernen ist ja praktisch nur die aller oberste Ebene der Oberfläche. Da gehört auch dazu, wie sie lernen. Und eben auch unter welchen Bedingungen sie lernen. Das bestimmt alles, was sie lernen können.
Und das ist historisch. Wie gesagt, ich muss wieder in die Geschichte, die Schule ist was Gewordenes, die Schule, so wie wir sie heute haben, nämlich als allgemein bildende Pflichtschule, das heißt es wird nicht Berufsbildung gemacht in dieser Schule. Also in der 10-12-jährigen Schule. Sondern es wird Allgemeinbildung, etwas für alle gleiches vermittelt, das ist zumindest der Anspruch und es müssen alle dran teilnehmen. Das klingt für die FDP nicht gut, weil die will die totale Freiheit des Individuums haben, aber es ist eine ganz große Errungenschaft, das wissen wir. Das wissen wir vor allen Dingen jetzt, wo wir sehen, wie die Bildung der staatlichen Kontrolle entzogen wird in manchen Ländern und privatisiert wird und zum Geschäft gemacht wird.
Da wissen wir plötzlich wieder, warum das gut ist, dass es eine allgemein bildende Pflichtschule ist. Das heißt nicht, dass man die Kinder, die nicht zur Schule kommen, ins Gefängnis stecken muss, was bei uns tatsächlich stattfindet, sondern das bedeutet eigentlich emphatisch, so war es von Humboldt gedacht, das Recht aller auf Bildung. Ein klassenübergreifendes Recht auf allgemeine gleiche Bildung. So kann man das beim emphatischen Humboldt finden, der Humboldt konnte das bloß nicht umsetzen, weil er unter die Kuratel des Innenministeriums gesteckt wurde, er sollte ja die Bildung aufbauen.
In Preußen.
In Preußen. Und das Innenministerium hat die Vorgaben gemacht und deswegen ist es natürlich im Obrigkeitsstaat was anderes geworden als Humboldt sich vorgestellt hat. Aber auf diesem emphatischen Humboldt kann man immer wieder zurückgreifen und sagen, so sollte es eigentlich sein. Und das ist ein Ergebnis der Aufklärung, was man nicht missachten darf. Im Gegenteil, heute wird es immer wieder wichtig, darauf in einer bestimmten Form zurückzugreifen. Nur heißt Allgemeinbildung natürlich auch historisch konkret immer was anderes. Weil jede historische Zeit braucht andere allgemeine Bildung. Das kann man sich schon mal ganz leicht daran vorstellen, dass zu Humboldts Zeiten denken lernen an den klassischen Fächern Griechisch, Latein und deutsche Literatur entwickelt wurde.
Nach der Entwicklung der Naturwissenschaften, die ja seitdem weit in Vorlage gegangen sind. Die in Natur- und Ingenieurwissenschaften, auch weil man damit Geld machen kann, natürlich. Das hat mit dem Kapitalismus zu tun. Aber kann man heute nicht mehr sagen, daran kann man kritisch denken entwickeln. Ich kann nicht mehr an den alten Stoffen und in diesem alten Modus das kritische Denken entwickeln und vor allen Dingen, noch als ich zur Schule gegangen bin in den Anfang der 60er Jahre bin ich eingeschult worden, waren 8% eines Jahrgangs Gymnasiasten, mit Aufnahmeprüfung. Es war also mitnichten eine klassenübergreifende Allgemeinbildung, sondern es hat eine höhere Bildung gegeben für die 8% - heute würden wir sagen – Elite, Sprösslinge. Und der Rest hat was ganz anderes gelernt. Hat also eine viel rudimentärere Bildung gelernt.
Und auch das ist bei uns übrig geblieben, die 3-Klassen-Bildung. In Bayern ist es tatsächlich noch eine 3-Klassen-Bildung mit Hauptschule, Mittelschule und Gymnasium. In Hamburg haben wir es wenigstens zu einer 2-Klassen-Bildung gebracht. Aber der – sage ich mal so – nicht herrschenden Klasse.
Berlin auch jüngst.
Ja. Die hat nicht so wahnsinnig viel davon. Weil es natürlich auch dazu geführt hat, dass die meisten, oder dass inzwischen 50% eines Jahrgangs ans Gymnasium gehen, also ist es doch wieder die Restschule für die anderen aus den sogenannten bildungsfernen Elternhäusern. Man vermeidet damit immer so schön die Klassenrealität benennen zu müssen. Ich tue das inzwischen. Ich hoffe ich bin so alt, dass man mir deswegen nicht mehr an meine Karriere fährt, die ich sowieso nicht gemacht habe. Also ja.
Also höre ich da raus, dass ein einheitliches Schulsystem am Ende sinnvoller wäre?
Ja. Das wissen wir aber auch schon lange eigentlich. Und alle Pisa-Erhebungen zeigen das auch. Ich weiß nicht, was der Grund ist. Aber auf den Pisa-Koordinator Andreas Schleicher hört man in Deutschland nicht gerne. Aber der hat aufklärerische Sachen zu verkünden. Den kann man nicht einfach abtun als jemand, der in diese böse neoliberale OECD gehört, die ist auch sehr widersprüchlich in sich. Der weist immer wieder darauf hin, dass alle erfolgreichen Schulsysteme Einheitsschulsystem sind. Den Begriff Einheitsschule nehmen wir hier in Deutschland nicht gerne entgegen, weil das war der Name für das Schulsystem der DDR. Und da haut uns immer noch der alte Antikommunismus, den wir als Frontland sozusagen – ich in Westberlin war ja auch noch in der Frontstadt damals – besonders vor uns hertragen.
Also eine Schule für alle ist der moderne Name dafür. Und es gibt es nun jetzt seit 20 Jahren in allen Ländern, in vielen Ländern in der letzten Zeit auch in Schwellenländern. Es gibt diese gespaltene Schule, die selektierende Schule, wo uns ja auch immer wieder nachgewiesen wird, dass wir in Deutschland damit Herkunft bewerten. Also dass Herkunft immer noch den Bildungserfolg bestimmt und zwar grob in Deutschland. Dass das mit dem gegliederten Schulsystem zu tun hat. Und 25% funktionale Analphabeten, also die nur rudimentär lesen und schreiben können. Die nicht sinnentnehmend Texte verstehen und nicht Herr ihres Lebens werden können dadurch. Weil sie gar nicht teilnehmen können.
Noch mit der untersten Literacy teilnehmen können am gesellschaftlichen Leben. Damit meine ich jetzt nicht auf Bälle gehen oder in die Elbphilharmonie gehen, sondern mit gesellschaftlichen Leben meine ich, Politik mit zu bestimmen. Das kann man nur, wenn man die Literacy hat. Und die primäre Literacy, also lesen und schreiben können, haben in den großen Ballungszentren, also wenn wir von so was reden, in unseren Metropolen, in den Stadtstaaten Bremen, Berlin, Hamburg mindestens 20% der Schüler, die durchs Schulsystem gelaufen sind und am Ende Abschluss oder auch nicht gemacht haben mit 15 Jahren eben nicht. Das ist immerhin ¼. 1/5 20% bis 25%, also mindestens 1/5 der Schüler geht ohne wirkliche primäre Literacy bei uns von der Schule.
Das ist im Bildungsland Deutschland eigentlich nicht erträglich. Und das hat natürlich mit dem gegliederten System was zu tun, aber auch nicht nur. Das hat auch was damit zu tun, dass wir in Deutschland tatsächlich was die Einbindung der digitalen Medien, also der neuen kulturbildenden Medialität in die Bildungsinstitutionen, dass wir so weit hinten dran sind. Denn auch die primäre Literacy gibt es unter Bedingungen der Digitalität nur noch, indem man auch gleichzeitig die digitale Literacy erwirbt.
Aber das Problem bestand ja im Prinzip auch schon vorher.[00:28:48-6 @lisarosa>Ja.
Wenn man jetzt sagt, Schule für alle, heißt jetzt nicht zwangsläufig, alle sollen dieselbe Zeit in der Schule verbringen oder? Das heißt nicht, dass man über denselben langen Zeitraum in der Schule verbleibt, oder heißt es das?
Also das klingt so pejorativ, das klingt so negativ. Also die Frage ist, ob ich Schulzeit zu lang finde und sie gern verkürzen möchte, entweder den Tag oder die Jahre, hängt ja davon ab, ob sie für mich was bringt. Bildungszeit ist Lebenszeit, wenn ich die nützlich verbringe in der Institution, weil das toll ist, was da gemacht wird, dann möchte ich so lange wie möglich da sein. Wenn es aber nichts taugt und nicht das bringt, was ich eigentlich brauche und nur meine Lebenszeit da verbraucht wird und ich da nur absitzen müssen, dann möchte ich sie natürlich verkürzen. Also es ist eine Frage dessen, welche Qualität das hat, ob es Sinn macht, es lang oder kurz zu haben.
Na gut, aber ich meine, wenn wir von einer allgemein bildenden Pflichtschule reden, dann steckt da ja im Prinzip auch drin, so also du gehst da nicht nur ein Jahr hin, sondern du verbringst schon eine gewisse Mindestzeit dort. Die Frage ist, ist die Mindestzeit auch die Maximalzeit, die man dort verbringen kann und sollte oder heißt Schule für alle nur, alle haben denselben Rahmen, können sich aber innerhalb dieses Rahmens so lange entwickeln wie sie möchten, aber eben mit einer gewissen Mindestaufenthaltszeit?
Ja, also die Schulzeit ist eigentlich…
Ich meine es gibt ja …
… historisch in eine andere Richtung…
Du hast ja erwähnt, es gibt erfolgreiche Modelle, die im Prinzip diesem Schema folgen. Funktionieren die so?
Ja also da gibt es zwei Sachen zu zu sagen. Historisch ist die Entwicklung der Schulzeit emanzipatorisch gesehen immer länger geworden. Wir haben angefangen mit einer vierjährigen Volksschule historisch und danach waren die Kinder fertig, um in die Lehre zu gehen. Entsprechend früh, das war ja noch praktisch Kinderarbeit, entsprechend früh sind sie ja auch in die Lehre gekommen. Nach der 6. Klasse in Drittweltländern wird drum gerungen, die Schulzeit zu verlängern über die vier oder fünf Jahre hinaus, vor allen Dingen für Mädchen, die noch ein Jahr früher aufhören und so weiter. Also historisch gesehen ist die Verlängerung der Schulzeit eigentlich eine Verbesserung der Bildung gewesen oder verknüpft gewesen mit einer Verbesserung der Bildung. Und die zehnjährige oder neunjährige gemeinsame Schulzeit verpflichtend für alle, zum Beispiel in Finnland oder damals in der DDR.
Wo man dann noch, wenn man noch weiter machen wollte und Hochschulreife bekommen wollte, eben noch zwei Jahre weitergemacht hat, das war eine Errungenschaft. Und die kann es auch als Errungenschaft bleiben und man würde nicht sagen, möglichst früh wieder weg aus der Schule, wenn dort was sinnvolles stattfindet. Wenn da aber etwas stattfindet, was anachronistisch ist und wenn viel Zeit verplempert wird mit Dingen, die eigentlich überholt sind, dann ist eigentlich jedes Jahr zu schade. Vielleicht sollte man mal drauf zu sprechen kommen, was eigentlich die Kompetenzen oder das Wissen ist, was man in der Schule erwerben muss, um auf einem möglichst hohen Niveau an der Gesellschaft als Individuum teilhaben zu können und für sich seine Rechte reklamieren und umsetzen kann.
Und auf einem möglichst hohen Niveau auch für die Gesellschaft zur Entwicklung der Gesellschaft was beitragen kann.
Gerne, welche Kompetenzen sind das?
Das sind eben andere als im Moment in der Vielzahl der Erscheinungsformen der Schule noch bearbeitet und gelernt werden.
Dann fangen wir doch damit mal an. Also was sind sozusagen die derzeit geschätzten Kompetenzen, auf die die Schule versucht hinzuarbeiten?
Also was angesagt wird, was die sogenannte Papierlage ist und was tatsächlich umgesetzt wird, sind ja immer noch zwei verschiedene Dinge. Und die Ansage ist natürlich, zu einem mündigen Bürger zu erziehen. Also Absichtserklärung, die Schüler sollen rauskommen aus der Schule und mündige Bürger sein, um in der Demokratie ihr Scherflein beizutragen und ihre Rechte einzuholen. Das hat ja nun nicht unbedingt was damit zu tun, dass die Art und Weise, wie Schule das organisiert, auch dazu passt. Und natürlich wird bei uns jetzt nicht, wie man sich das vielleicht vorstellt, den ganzen Tag nur auswendig gelernt. Es gibt tatsächlich Systeme, wo das so stattfindet. Das ist bei uns aber schon in der Regel nicht mehr. Aber also wir haben ganz viel von der Reformpädagogik auch in die Schulen getragen. Zunächst übrigens in den Grundschulen.
Dann kamen Grundschüler an die Gymnasien und waren schon selbständigeres Lernen gewohnt als in der 5. Klasse am Gymnasium ihnen dann wieder vorgesetzt wurde. Und dann haben die gesagt, hoppla wir sind es eigentlich gewohnt, dass wir aussuchen dürfen, wann wir welche Texte bearbeiten oder welches Fach wir jetzt lernen wollen. Und dann musste sich mühsam auch das Gymnasium darauf einstellen, bestimmte Dinge ins Offene zu bringen. Also nicht mehr genau vorzuschreiben.
Von welchem Zeitraum reden wir jetzt?
Von den letzten 20 Jahren. Oder sagen wir von den letzten 15 genauer. Trotzdem und jetzt kommen wir zu dem Unterschied, Personen, die was machen in der Schule, also Lehrer, die was wollen oder Papiere, die was verkünden, was eigentlich hinterher dabei rauskommen soll und Struktur wie du das nennst. Das alles findet in der Struktur und in dem System statt, was noch genauso ist wie vor 200 Jahren. Es gibt Klassen, Fächer, die in 45, wenn wir Glück haben, in Hamburg ist das ein bisschen voraus, hat man wenigstens zwei Stunden zusammengelegt, die im stündlichen Wechsel unterrichtet werden von immer auch wieder wechselnden Lehrern und überhaupt keine Rücksicht darauf nehmen, wo der Lernende jetzt gerade ist. Also was jedem Lehrer passiert, wenn er mal guten Unterricht hinkriegt.
Nicht weil er ein schlechter Lehrer wäre kriegt er das nicht immer hin, sondern weil er nicht alleine bestimmt, wie der Unterricht laufen kann. Wenn dem Lehrer also tatsächlich mal eine gute Stunde gelingt, kann es ihm passieren, dass die Schulklingel die Schüler aus ihrer Arbeit rausreißt und ein Schüler impulsiv sagt, och wie schade, jetzt habe ich gerade Spaß gekriegt. Und umgekehrt weiß man natürlich sitzen die Schüler und starren auf die Uhr über der Tafel oder über der Tür, wenn sie da hängt und warten, dass die Zeit vorbeigeht und dass es endlich klingelt, damit sie sich endlich auf dem Hof wieder mit ihren Freunden treffen können, weil da das eigentliche Leben stattfindet. Das ist eine Organisation, die ist wirklich wie im Kaiserreich. Und die Klassen sind geschlossen. Also man bejubelt dann wunderbar jetzt, dass neue Räumlichkeiten, neue Schularchitektur entsteht, wo man von außen in die Klassen reingucken kann, ganz was erstaunliches.
Es ändert im Grunde genommen an dem ganzen Setting aber überhaupt nichts. Der Lehrer macht hinter seiner Klassentür und sage ich mal so führt seinen Unterricht durch und es schaut niemand dabei zu. Es ist nicht üblich, dass jemand reinkommt und dabei ist und einfach zuguckt. Es sei denn es ist ein Lehrerausbilder und ein Prüfer. Ich weiß nicht, ob Lehrer gewohnt sind inzwischen, dass sie sich, wenn sie Probleme haben, einen Kollegen dazu bitten und sagen, guck doch du mal kritisch auf meinen Unterricht oder da was da passiert irgendwie. Mit der Klasse habe ich Probleme, da läuft es irgendwie nicht rund, kannst du mir mal helfen? Das ist überhaupt nicht üblich. Es gibt in solchen Systemen auch ungeschriebene Gesetze und Regeln, an die sich alle halten.
Wie zum Beispiel, ich komm schon alleine klar? Oder dass man das nicht macht?
Ja, dass man es nicht macht. Also ich weiß noch, ich hatte mit einer Klasse mal furchtbare Schwierigkeiten und habe meinen Direktor mindestens dreimal gebeten, doch mal in die Klasse zu kommen und zu gucken. Weil ich gedacht habe, das ist doch meine Aufsichtsperson, der kann mir doch helfen, der muss mich doch beraten. Der ist nie gekommen. Und zwar immer wenn ich nachgefragt habe, warum er denn nicht kommt, hat er immer systemisch gesprochen, das heißt er hat gesagt, Sie haben doch Ihre Überprüfung schon längst gehabt. Das heißt er hat das als Überprüfung verstanden, ich wollte ihn aber als Berater haben. Und diese Beraterfunktion gibt es in der Schule nicht. Jeder Lehrer arbeitet für sich in seiner Klasse. Auch wenn alle am gleichen Curriculum sich orientieren müssen. Und es ist halt eine hierarchische Organisation. Da gibt es Vorgesetzte auf verschiedenen Ebenen und zum Schluss kommt die Schulaufsicht und das ist ja eine recht steile Hierarchie insgesamt.
Das ist ja auch Behörde und nicht irgendeine Form der Organisation. Die hält das Ganze auf der hierarchischen Ebene zusammen und deswegen ist es so schwierig, das, was eigentlich gebracht wird, im 21. Jahrhundert jetzt auch, um diese Kompetenzen, die ich gleich nochmal nennen werde, überhaupt zu etablieren, auch systemisch zu etablieren, dass sich die Lehrer zusammensetzen können und sich gemeinsam beraten. Es gibt natürlich eine Fachkonferenz, aber darüber will ich jetzt gar nicht reden. Es gibt natürlich auch die Möglichkeit, dass sich Lehrer zusammensetzen, um was zu besprechen, das verbietet keiner. Nur es gibt keine Arbeitszeit dafür. Die Arbeitszeit wird in Unterrichtsstunden gemessen. Und alles andere, besonders im Hamburger Modell, ist sage ich mal so dazu gefegtes minutenmäßiges.
Rein gerechnet, wie viel Zeit wird man wohl brauchen minimal, um eine Klausur zu korrigieren, um mal mit Eltern zu reden, das ist alles ganz stiefmütterlich behandelt. Das eigentliche sogenannte Kerngeschäft ist die Unterrichtsstunde. Und früher hatten wir das ja so, dass die mal zwei gerechnet wurde. Ich bin eingestiegen mit 23 Stunden Unterrichtsverpflichtung, das wurde mal zwei gedacht. Dann hat man 46 Stunden Arbeitswoche. Das kommt hin, wenn man rechnet, dass es immerhin 12 Wochen Ferien gibt und nicht nur 6. Und dann stimmt das, dann hat der Lehrer eben wieder seine 30 Tage Jahresurlaub.
Diese doppelte Stunde ist dann halt für Vorbereitung, Nachbereitung?
Ganz genau, Vorbereitung, Nachbereitung, Korrigieren, reden mit den Eltern, an Konferenzen teilnehmen, es war schon das knapp gerechnet, aber immerhin. Und das ist im Hamburger Arbeitszeitmodell aufgelöst worden und dadurch wurde eigentlich die Arbeitszeit noch dichter. Also es hat nicht eine Verbesserung gegeben, sondern es war ein Sparmodell und die Arbeitszeit wurde noch dichter. Also angeblich sollte man in 13 Minuten eine Oberstufendeutschklausur mit 27 Seiten korrigieren und dann auch noch Rechtschreibkorrigieren und dann auch noch was gescheites dazu schreiben. Ja das ist der Rahmen, unter dem Schule sage ich mal so die Denke der Schule, die Philosophie der Schule läuft. Und jeder einzelne Lehrer der muss in diesem Rahmen spielen, weil er ihn ja nicht verändern kann. Und da ist seine eigene Handlungsmöglichkeit schon relativ gut eingeschränkt, einfach durch die Zeit. Die Zeit spielt eine Rolle.
Und das verhindert dann in gewisser Hinsicht auch eine Teambildung unter den Lehrern?
Das verhindert, dass man ordentlich miteinander reden kann und ordentlich ein Team bilden kann. In Finnland ist es zum Beispiel so, dass die Lehrer eine viel niedrigere Unterrichtsverpflichtung haben. Also weniger Unterrichtszeit. Aber die liegen dann nicht auf der faulen Haut in der Zeit, sondern in der übrigen Zeit, also die Differenz zu unserer hier in Deutschland oder in Hamburg ausmacht, sondern die ist strategisch eingeplant als Konferenzzeit im Team. Du musst in der Zeit mit den anderen über die Schüler sprechen, über den Unterricht sprechen und so weiter. Also sie haben eine viel größere nicht nur Freiheit von der Zeit her, sondern auch gesetzte Strukturen, die man ja auch braucht dafür, um sich zu treffen. Das kann ja nicht alles nur selbst organisiert sein, um miteinander über Unterrichtsprobleme oder über Schüler zu sprechen. Das ist bei uns ganz stiefmütterlich.
Und das ist aber eine der wesentlichen Gründe dafür, warum kein Aas, bis auf wenige wirklich Heroen sage ich mal so, sich damit beschäftigt, digitale Medien im Unterricht einzusetzen. Digitale Medien im Unterricht einzuführen und komplett den Unterricht neu zu gestalten unter ganz anderen Bedingungen. Das ist ja nicht nur so, dass du jetzt das gleiche machst wie vorher, nur mit digitalen Medien statt mit Buch. Wie man immer so schön sagt analog, was ja eigentlich falsch ist. Sondern du musst ja eigentlich deine gesamte Lehre verändern und umstellen. Das hat ja unglaubliche Folgen, wenn du es ernst meinst. Wenn du es nicht ernst meinst, dann kommt was schlimmeres dabei raus als ohne digitale Medien. Dafür gibt es auch Beispiele. Ja aber dafür braucht man Zeit.
Und man braucht nicht nur die Zeit dafür, etwas neues auszuprobieren, das zu beobachten, sich mit anderen auszutauschen, um Erfahrungen auszutauschen, aber auch um Dinge zu klären, die vor die Wand gefahren sind und zu analysieren, warum sie vor die Wand gefahren sind, damit man in einem neuen Anlauf, in einer neuen Proberunde was verbessern kann und so weiter. Nur so entstehen ja Innovationen überhaupt. Dafür braucht man nicht nur Zeit, die wir nicht haben. Sondern dafür braucht man auch eine andere Haltung. Und das ist diese Experimentierhaltung und die passt auch nicht zu dieser alten Schule. Ich weiß noch, wie wir neue Dinge einführen wollten. Ich war ja auch mal jung und ich kam aus der 68er Zeit, und als wir als junge Referendare in die Schule kamen, haben wir auch geklopft und gesagt, wir wollen hier den Laden mal ein bisschen auffrischen.
Den Talarenmuff von 1000 Jahren.
Die Lehrer und auch die Studienräte hatten keine Talare, aber da musste ja auch was verändert werden. Jedenfalls die junge Generation ist ja immer dafür da, dass sie neuen Wind reinbringt. Und da hieß es ganz besonders für die Schule, wir dürfen nicht auf dem Rücken unserer Kinder experimentieren. Das ist auch heute noch eines der schlimmsten Dinge, mit denen man alles neuere verhindern kann, indem gesagt wird, unsere Kinder sind keine Versuchskaninchen, das ist die Parole.
Sondern wir müssen Ihnen auch immer das Bewährte bieten können.
Und es muss alles erst mal sorgfältig von der Wissenschaft evaluiert sein und von dem Professor XY beobachtet und beschrieben worden sein und dann noch diskutiert mit möglichst allen anderen Professoren. Jetzt kann man sich vorstellen, warum wir so eine Rücklage haben und so viel nicht schaffen, weil das dauert 10 Jahre.
Wo man ja weiß, dass Kinder ja wirklich der Teil der Gesellschaft sind, die sich am schwierigsten auf neue Bedingungen einstellen.
Ja genau, aber es geht ja gar nicht um die Kinder in der Schule. Es geht ja offensichtlich um was anderes. Also das sind die alten Verhältnisse, die sich nicht dadurch ändern, dass man jetzt die Smartphones da reinbringt. Also ich kann nicht an einer Stelle an einer Schraube drehen und dann glauben, dann verändert sich das ganze System. Dieses Bild mit den Schrauben, was immer so gerne genommen wird, das muss man sich ja mal klar machen, das stammt ja aus der Zeit dieses Systems. Nämlich eine mechanische Vorstellung von einer Maschine, wo alle Schräubchen ineinandergreifen und wenn ich an einer Stelle drehe, dann machen alle Schrauben das brav mit. Aber wir wissen doch schon längst, dass diese Wertvorstellung aus der Industriezeit stammt, aus der wir ja nun gerade rausgewachsen sind. Und wir wissen nicht zuletzt über die Digitalität und die damit entstandene Kybernetik und die damit entstandene Systemtheorie, die sind gemeinsam entstanden.
Das gehört zur technologischen Weltkonzeptions- und Denkentwicklung, dass wir in komplexen Systemen leben, wenn wir in so was wie Schule arbeiten. Und dass da keine Schräubchen sind, die ineinandergreifen, das ist die Obrigkeitsvorstellung. Der Lehrer dreht oben an der Schraube und unten macht der Schüler klick, Trivialmaschine und liefert genau das, was der Lehrer oben reingesteckt hat.
Computerdenken schon fast. Ich würde gern nochmal einen kurzen Moment noch diese digitale Revolution noch ein bisschen außen vor lassen. Um das nochmal besser voneinander trennen zu können. Sagen wir mal, wir hätten jetzt diese ganze Entwicklung mit dem Internet nicht gehabt oder wir konzentrieren uns einfach nur so auf den Zustand vielleicht Ende der 80er Jahre, wo das ja zwar schon irgendwie da war, aber eben noch lange nicht so präsent. Die eben beschriebenen Probleme, dass man sich vielleicht auf die falschen Kompetenzen konzentriert und dass die Arbeit der Lehrer zu sehr auf den vortragsorientierten Lehrbetrieb konzentriert ist und man sich weniger um eine Teamfähigkeit kümmert und weniger den Lehrkörper verbunden sieht mit den Schülern, wie hätte man denn das sozusagen zu dem Zeitpunkt ändern müssen oder können? Mal ganz unabhängig jetzt von der ganzen digitalen Entwicklung, die ja jetzt noch oben mit drauf kommt?
Ja ich sehe das eben nicht so, dass da was oben mit drauf kommt, sondern dass das systemisch miteinander zu tun hat. Und als Historiker zu fragen, was wäre gewesen, wenn? Ist ein schönes Gedankenspiel.
Aber es funktioniert nicht?
Ah doch, da kann man interessante Sachen bei rauskriegen, man muss sich nur immer klar machen, dass das mit der Realität eben nichts zu tun hat. Weil die Realität ist das was gewesen ist.
Na klar.
So was aber sicher falsch ist, ist anzunehmen, dass wir, auch in den letzten 20 Jahren war das nicht so, einen Unterricht haben, wo der Lehrer vorne vorträgt. Ich würde mich freuen, wenn die Lehrer gute Vortragende wären. Die tragen nichts mehr vor. Ein Lehrer, der einen Vortrag plötzlich halten muss irgendwo, ist verraten und verkauft, weil das überhaupt nicht zu seinen Kompetenzen gehört. Dafür ist er ja auch nicht ausgebildet. Das muss er sich dann wenn dann mühsam aneignen. Wie hält man denn eigentlich einen Vortrag, mit Anfang, Mitte, Schluss und ah eine halbe Stunde ist eine ganze Menge Zeit, die man systematisch was vortragen muss. Die muss man sich organisieren und ist ja fast so schlimm, wie einen Aufsatz schreiben. Nein so läuft bei uns der Unterricht natürlich schon ganz lange nicht mehr. Sondern der Lehrer organisiert den Unterricht in kleinen Häppchen. So habe ich auch vor 40 Jahren in meinem eigenen Referendariat unterrichten gelernt. Wir haben eine Unterrichtsstunde von 45 Minuten. Ziele, Absichten und Material legen wir natürlich fest, das ist klar, das ist in Lehrerhand.
Das ist ja was, was ich auch kritisiere. Und dann sagen wir, ja wie macht man jetzt 45 Minuten daraus. Sie müssen, so nennt sich das, rhythmisiert werden. Dann macht der Lehrer eine Minute abfragen von Wissen von gestern oder vom letzten Mal, dann braucht er vielleicht auch noch fünf Minuten, um die Klasse überhaupt zur Ruhe zu bringen, dass sie nicht über Tisch und Bänke gehen, sondern sitzen und zuhören und in den Aufnahmemodus kommen. Dann startet er mit seinem eigentlichen Unterricht, führt ins Thema ein. Dazu braucht er 1-2 Minuten oder er lässt einen Schüler vortragen oder irgendwas oder er zeigt ein Bild, stummen Impuls und dann kriegen die Schüler vor allen Dingen Material. Sie kriegen Arbeitsbögen vorgelegt, die sie ausfüllen sollen. Sie kriegen eine Lehrbuchseite genannt, wo sie was tun sollen. Und alle spätestens Viertstunde wechselt die Phase und dann wird es wieder anders organisiert.
Dann gibt es ein neues Material, dann gibt es manchmal passen die Sachen, wenn es schlecht ist, auch noch nicht mal zusammen und sind irgendwie nicht in sich kohärent. Also es ist nicht das was man sich – ja frag mal deine Kinder, die erzählen dir, wie der Unterricht läuft – und du kannst übrigens bei Anja Reschke, habe ich in meinem Blog irgendwann drüber geschrieben vor Jahren, hat es mal eine interessante Unterrichtsbeobachtung gegeben, die auch im Fernsehen gezeigt wurde. Da hat eine Journalistin, Anja Reschke heißt sie, hat am Unterricht teilgenommen und hat den Unterricht glaube ich sogar mit vorbereitet. Und dann haben sie den Unterricht gefilmt und waren hinterher ganz ratlos und hilflos, warum der Unterricht so vor die Wand gelaufen ist. Ich hätte beim Beobachten sagen können, warum. Aber das ist …
Also wer war ratlos? Die beachtenden Journalisten?
Ja Lehrer auch, alle.
Alle.
Und das Problem ist eben, dass man sich wirklich vorstellt, dass die Schüler das machen, was man ihnen sagt. Das können sie ja äußerlich sogar alle tun, aber die Vorstellung, dass das identisch damit ist, was in ihren Köpfen vorgeht, ist natürlich vollkommener Unsinn. Aber so werden die Schüler verstanden. Als Trivialmaschine, in deren Köpfen das abläuft, was ich möchte, das drin abläuft, wenn ich nur den richtigen Impuls dafür gebe. Und so einfach ist es eben nicht. Vor allen Dingen, wenn man die Schüler nicht selber reden lässt. Wenn man die Schüler … das ist der einzige Ausweg, dass man die Schüler reden lässt und eine echte Kommunikation zustande bringt. Und zwar eine, wo nicht der Lehrer die Schüler fragt und die Schüler müssen antworten, sondern wo der Lehrer die Schüler nach ihrer Meinung fragt und wo die Schüler ihre Fragen stellen dürfen und an den Fragen dann auch arbeiten dürfen.
Und das ist aber eine uralte Pädagogik, die stammt von Dewey, dem pragmatischen Philosophen aus den USA. Ist über 100 Jahre her.
Dewey?
D E W E Y. Der hat die Vorstellung einer demokratischen Schule gehabt. Der hat das Projektlernen erfunden, will ich jetzt mal so kurz sagen. Es gibt noch andere, die dabei waren und dazu gehören, aber das ist die Hauptrichtung. Und der hat gesagt, die Schüler – der hat übrigens auch diese Demokratievorstellung in der Bildung so umgesetzt. Er hat auch eine eigene Schule. Und er hat die Schüler gefragt, was sie lernen wollen. Und er hat Probleme aus der Realität genommen und hat an Problemen die Schüler arbeiten lassen und hat ihnen was anderes gegeben, nicht Stoff, nicht Wissen, nicht Inhalte, fertiges, sondern hat ihnen den Rahmen dafür gegeben und die Hilfestellung, also über Methodologien, wie man an das Wissen rankommt, was man jetzt braucht, um dieses Problem zu lösen. Aber es war ein Problem, was die Schüler genannte hatten.
Und sie haben auch selber die Relevanz des Themas quasi damit ja auch gleich mit in den Vordergrund gestellt, weil das ist ja das, was sie beschäftigt.
Ja natürlich ganz genau. Und das hat natürlich genau auch mit der Motivbildung zu tun. Also wenn unsere Schüler nicht motiviert sind, darüber klagt ja jeder Lehrer, dass er Schüler hat, die in ihren Sesseln lümmeln und eigentlich keinen Bock haben und das auch sehr deutlich zeigen. Sich vielleicht sogar mit was anderem beschäftigen oder stören, wie man so sagt, den Lehrer bei seiner Arbeit stören, ist ja auch eine ulkige Vorstellung. Was das wohl für eine Arbeit ist, bei der man ihn da stören kann. Ja jedenfalls darüber klagt jeder Lehrer, auch am Gymnasium haben wir damit Probleme. Und die Vorstellung, dass das vielleicht damit zu tun haben könnte, dass tatsächlich die Schüler nicht beteiligt sind an dem was sie lernen, dass das eigentlich die Grundlage dafür ist, dass man überhaupt lernt. Würdest du was lernen wollen, was du nicht selber lernen willst? Das ist ja schon in sich …
Wollte ich noch nie eigentlich.
Nein und ich glaube niemand will das. Und früher war die …
Aber die Angst ist ja so ein bisschen, dass wenn man das so laufen lässt, dass dann bestimmte Dinge, die man als lernwichtig erachtet, dann niemals erlernt werden, weil sie nie hinterfragt werden.
Aber das ist ja eine komische Vorstellung. Du bist dann der einzige, der das was gelernt werden soll, lernen würde. Die anderen alle nicht. Weil die anderen alle ja so faul sind. Also das ist das Menschenbild, was da hinversteckt. Das ist ja irgendwie krass. Das ist die Vorstellung, dass wenn die Schüler lernen dürften, was sie wollten, dann wollen sie eigentlich nichts lernen und nur Ferien haben oder dummes Zeug lernen. Ich habe ja meinen Unterricht mal komplett umgestellt vom belehrenden Lernen zum Projektlernen. Das war in den 0er Jahren. Da habe ich angefangen, nur noch Projektlernen zu machen, wo auch immer das möglich war in allen Fächern und es war möglich und es war sehr spannend, obwohl es sehr wild war, weil ich keine Methodologie hatte. Ich kannte nämlich den Dewey noch nicht, den habe ich erst später kennengelernt. Jedenfalls war natürlich zuerst so, dass viele Schüler gesagt haben, ach wenn wir machen dürfen, was wir wollen, dann gehen wir am liebsten nach Hause.
Da habe ich gesagt, nein das dürft ihr nicht, ihr müsst hier sein. Aber ihr dürft lernen, was ihr wollt. Ja dann wollen wir das. Dann habe ich gesagt, das Fach heißt Musik. Ihr dürft lernen, was ihr wollt, es muss was mit Musik zu tun haben und dann ist es frei. Und dann kamen sieben Gruppen raus, die wollten komponieren die eine Gruppe, die andere Gruppe wollte was spielen lernen auf dem Keyboard. Eine andere Gruppe wollte Filmmusik analysieren und so weiter. Ich hatte plötzlich in der 8. Klasse sieben verschiedene Projektgruppen. Du kannst dir vorstellen, was das für ein wilder Haufen war. Aber der Witz war, ich habe sie ernst genommen und ich habe gesagt, ja wir probieren das, wir machen das. Und das ist jetzt unser Projekt. Das muss hinhauen. Und die haben alle gearbeitet wie die verrückten und ich habe sieben Räume belegt, um die sieben Projektgruppen unterzubringen. Und es war einstündiger Unterricht. Die sind tatsächlich ein halbes Jahr lang am Ball geblieben, um ihre Projekte zu Ende zu führen. Und ich musste dann von einem Raum zum anderen rennen, um immer die Probleme zu lösen und zu beraten.
Und ach wir brauchen noch hier einen Kassettenrekorder Frau Rosa und wir brauchen noch dies und jenes, ich war nur noch am Durchdrehen und Rennen. Ich kannte eben Deweys Projektmethodologie noch nicht. Aber im Grunde genommen habe ich verstanden, worauf es ankommt und das mit den Schülern geteilt und die Schüler haben mir das als richtig zurückgespiegelt. Dass sie dann hochengagiert sind und auch der letzte in die Hufe kommt und auch der letzte sich anstrengt, um zu zeigen, dass wenn sie lernen dürfen, was sie wollen, und die Fragestellung oder das Thema oder was mitbestimmen dürfen, dass sie dann sofort mit dabei sind.
Es ist noch nicht mal die Präsenz, zumindest nicht die dauerhafte Präsenz der Lehrer erfordert.
Nein bei vielem ja nicht. Also wenn was in Gang gekommen ist, dann ist es selbstorganisierend bis Probleme auftauchen. Und mit einer gescheiten Projektmethodologie kann man diese Probleme nach einer Weile alle voraussehen.
War das für dich dann auch einfacher oder nicht auch erst mal eine größere Belastung?
Ja es war anstrengend, aber es hat mehr Spaß gemacht. Ich hatte wieder Lust, zu arbeiten. Und ich hatte das Gefühl, es ist eine gute Kommunikation da und die Schüler fühlten sich respektiert, das haben sie mir auch so gesagt.
Ernst genommen?
Ja. Und es war anstrengend, aber diese wilde Art von Projektarbeit muss man ja nicht machen. Es gibt ja, habe ich erst später kennengelernt, diese Deweysche Projektmethodologie, darüber habe ich selber auch geschrieben und veröffentlicht und das kann man heute lernen. Was mich nur wundert ist, dass diese wunderbare Projektmethodologie nicht verpflichtender Bestandteil in der Lehrerausbildung ist.
Was macht denn diese Methodologie jetzt genau aus?
Die dreht alles rum. Die macht, und das ist der Charme an ihr, das kann sie sogar eigentlich, ohne das System schlimm zu verändern. Also man muss ja immer gucken, wie passt sich das da ein. Man kann ja nicht ein System zerschlagen und dann ist nichts. Dann ist Deutschland in Ruinen und dann baut man ein neues auf. Sondern man muss ja immer anschlussfähig was verändern und das geht eben mit dieser Projektmethodologie. Ich glaube auch, das ist die einzige, die anschlussfähig ist. Es muss nur wenig geändert werden, aber im Kopf des Lehrers muss eine Menge geändert werden. Nämlich er muss sich vorstellen, dass alles, was er bisher vorgegeben hat, nämlich die Ergebnisse, die Lernziele, das was hinten bei rauskommen soll und die konkreten Gegenstände, an denen ein großes komplexes Thema bearbeitet wird, dass er das alles vorgibt und den Schülern auch noch das Material vor die Füße schmeißt und sagt, jetzt müsst ihr §3 bis 5 lesen und dann steht da noch eine Frage drunter und bitte beantwortet anschließend diese Frage und dann tragt ihr das bitte vor.
Das ist wie bei uns normal Unterricht verläuft. Um klarzumachen nochmal, eben nicht in dem der Lehrer Vorträge hält. Aber die Schüler führen Anweisungen eines Lehrers aus, der ihnen womöglich noch nicht mal gesagt hat, was hinten bei rauskommen soll. Also es fehlt sowieso an der Transparenz. Die Schüler werden sozusagen am Nasenring geführt mit bestimmten … ihnen wird vorgeschrieben, was sie jetzt tun sollen, was sie in fünf Minuten tun sollen, was sie dann tun sollen und so weiter, so ist moderner Unterricht. Ich drehe das um und Dewey hat das vor über 100 Jahren umgedreht und hat gesagt, nein die Schüler sollen selber bestimmen, was sie wie lernen wollen. Und die Lehrer müssen dafür ihnen, heute würde man sagen, Coaches sein. Also die Berater.
Dienstleister quasi.
Ja genau, wenn du das so lernen möchtest, dann überleg mal, was du dazu brauchst. Und dann machst du mir mal einen Zettel und schreibst auf, was du glaubst, was du da alles für brauchst und dann trägst du das vor und berätst dich mit deinen Peers, was die so rausgekriegt haben, was man braucht und dann sprecht ihr euch ab und dann kommt ihr zu mir und sagt, das und das brauchen wir. Und wenn ich das überzeugend finde, dann helfe ich euch dabei, das zu beschaffen. Das ist ja eine vollkommen andere Vorstellung, dass man als Lehrer eine Überfülle an Material vorhält, dass man ihnen die Strukturen dafür gibt, die Umgebungen würde man heute modern sagen, die Lernumgebung. Also sagt, ihr habe die nächsten drei Wochen Zeit, das ist ja eine Strukturvorgabe, was die Zeit angeht und in der Zeit könnt ihr zu eurer Lösung kommen. Und jetzt die erste Woche arbeiten wir mal, was sind eigentlich die Fragen, die euch umtreiben?
Also so bin ich an die KZ-Gedenkstätte hier in Hamburg in Neuengamme gegangen. Ich habe keinen Unterricht vorher gemacht, sondern bin mit den Schülern da hingegangen und habe gesagt, jetzt orientiert ihr euch mal hier und guckt euch um, was es hier eigentlich gibt und dann kommen wir wieder zusammen nach zwei Stunden in dem Raum und dann stellt ihr vor, was euch so beeindruckt hat. Und dann hatten die Schüler das alles fotografiert.
Also ohne Führung?
Ja. Und dann hatten die Schüler das alles fotografiert, was sie beeindruckt oder natürlich auch beunruhigt hat. Und das haben sie indem sie ein Foto an die Wand geworfen haben, das konnte man eben mit den digitalen Medien schon und haben dann gesagt, ja dieses Foto haben wir deswegen gewählt, weil uns das so unglaublich beeindruckt hat, dass …. Was weiß ich, es so viele verschiedene Häftlingsgruppen hier gab. Wir dachten, hier wären nur Juden gewesen. Und jetzt wollen wir mal darüber reden. Und die Schüler müssen ihre eigenen Fragen entwickeln. Weil das ist die einzige Möglichkeit, sinnvolle Lernmotive zu etablieren. Die mehr halten als das Motiv, ich will eine 1 In der Klausur schreiben. Oder die Schule produziert lauter solche Motive, ich will eine 1 schreiben, ich will ein gutes Abitur machen, ich möchte dem Lehrer gefallen. Das sind ernstzunehmende …
Oder ich muss diese Noten auch erhalten, um auf eine bessere Schule wechseln zu können.
Zum Beispiel. Aus unterschiedlichsten Gründen kann man gute Noten brauchen müssen. Das sind auch keine Motive, die man schlecht machen darf. Weil die Schule produziert sie. Einem Schüler jetzt zu sagen, du lernst ja nur, weil du ein gutes Abitur machen willst, ist ja echt Verarschung. Ja das gibt es aber. Die Vertreter dieser Ideologie, dass es intrinsische Motive gibt, die gut sind und extrinsische Motive, die sind schlecht, die machen das ja dauernd. Die reden dem Schüler, der eigentlich nichts weiter will als den Lehrer zufrieden zu stellen, ein gutes Abitur zu machen, weil er Medizin studieren will, das ist doch in Ordnung, die reden den auch noch schlecht und sagen, du willst ja bloß lernen, um Medizin zu studieren, das ist doch kein gutes Lernmotiv. Das ist nicht in Ordnung, nicht in so einer Schule.
Ja und vor allem, wenn es die Motivation ist, sollte man sich freuen darüber, dass es überhaupt eine gibt.
Ja das ist richtig. Aber eigentlich wollen wir ja natürlich, dass die Schüler lernen, weil sie es so spannend finden. Das kriegt man aber, wenn man ihnen den Stoff sozusagen zum Fraß vorwirft, inklusive der Fragen an den Stoff, inklusive der Problematik und inklusive einer völlig unklaren Vorstellung davon, was der Schüler mit dem Stoff eigentlich zu tun hat, Relevanz für ihn, nicht nur gesellschaftlich, kriegt man eigentlich ganz selten nur hin. Aber mit dieser Umdrehung der Verhältnisse, indem die Schüler Fragen an den Stoff stellen und dann tatsächlich an diesen Fragen auch arbeiten dürfen, angeleitet, unterstützt vom Lehrer, die bringt solche Motivationen natürlich eher hervor. Und dann werden natürlich nicht die Fragen gestellt, oder nicht immer, die der Lehrer gefragt hätte oder gut gefunden hätte, wenn sie gefragt werden. Aber die Möglichkeit, auch mal selber eine Frage zu stellen, hat der Lehrer ja immer.
Also wenn ich irgendwas wichtig finde, was in dem, was die Schüler gearbeitet haben, nicht vorkommt, dann kann ich mich ja selber als Lernender einbringen und sagen, also ich habe hier was gesehen, habt ihr das nicht auch gesehen? Das hat mich erschüttert, was würdet ihr denn dazu sagen? Und dann wird man als Gesprächspartner natürlich auch ganz anders ernst genommen, wenn die Schüler auch Gesprächspartner sind an der Sache. Im Grunde genommen muss Lernen so organisiert werden, dass die Sache auf den Tisch kommt, ein großes, wie wir sagen, komplexes Problem und dass jeder an dem Tisch sitzt, also Schüler und Lehrer, ein Gespräch über diese Sache führen, jetzt im übertragenden Sinne, Gespräch muss ja dann auch Butter bei die Fische und was erarbeitet werden, aber das ist die Initialgeschichte, dass man über eine Sache spricht und fragt, was hat das mit dir zu tun, mach dir einen Sinn draus.
Reden wir jetzt eigentlich über alle Jahrgänge oder klammern wir gerade irgendwas aus? Ist das etwas, was auch schon in der Grundschule auch zum Erlernen der Grundrechenarten, des Lesens, des Schreibens funktionieren kann?
Ja. Und es ist auch längst bestätigt in der Praxis.
Durch was?
Ja es gibt zum Beispiel, kannst du mal gucken, ist uralt, vor 20 Jahren Rolf Robischon in Baden-Württemberg, dem haben sie dann übel mitgespielt aus dem Kultusministerium. Der war Schulleiter an einer Grundschule. Der hat gesagt, meine Schüler dürfen die Sachen lernen wie und wann sie wollen. Ich gebe ihnen keine Aufträge, sondern ich präsentiere mich mit meinem Angebot und dann wollen wir mal sehen. Der war ein radikaler Konstruktivist, also jetzt nicht im philosophischen Sinne radikal, sondern in der Art, wie er gearbeitet hat, radikal. Und der hat so gut die Schüler zum Lernen gebracht. Die haben so gerne bei ihm gelernt, dass er angefangen hat, damals gab es noch gar nicht die Inklusion, dann angefangen hat, auch Trisomie 21, also Down-Syndrom-Kinder, in seinen Unterricht reinzuholen und gesagt haben, die lernen das auch, die lernen auch lesen und schreiben und rechnen bei mir.
Und sie haben es alle gelernt. Das kann man im Netz wiederfinden auf seiner Website. Lernen ist wie Netze spinnen, das ist sein Buch. Ja jedenfalls ist das ein Beispiel, dass es funktioniert. Also es ist erprobt und nachgewiesen und bewiesen, dass das für alle geht. Und dass eben die Schüler nicht sagen, das lernen wir nicht, wenn alles freiwillig ist, lernen wir das nicht. Lesen und schreiben, die Literacy, die grundlegende Kulturtechnik, um an der Gesellschaft teilzunehmen, das wollen alle. Es sei denn sie sind vollkommen daneben. Das wollen alle lernen, weil sie sonst von der Kommunikation ausgeschlossen sind. Kennst du ein Kind, was absichtlich sich von der Kommunikation generell und von dem Sozialleben ausschließen lassen möchte freiwillig?
Ganz im Gegenteil.
Auch Asperger und Autisten, also ich meine jetzt nicht die Kanner-Autisten, die wirklich bösartig krank sind, die leiden darunter, dass sie so einsam sind. Wenn die sich zurückziehen oder sich nerdig verhalten, dann liegt es an anderen Dingen, nicht weil sie nichts mit den Menschen zu tun haben wollen, sondern es liegt daran, dass sie immer missverstanden werden. Und die sind hoch einsam. Kein Mensch ist mit Absicht gerne von sich aus einsam und schon gar nicht als Kind. Jedes Kind will lesen und schreiben lernen. Aber nicht alle können das nach dem gleichen vorgegebenen Muster, deswegen haben wir dann plötzlich so viele, die das aus irgendwelchen Gründen, die werden dann zu Kranken erklärt. Also Legastheniker und und und.
Weil sie einfach mit dem System, wie es erläutert wird, nicht klarkommen und nicht weil sie es nicht vielleicht grundsätzlich könnten.
Genau. Ja, also ich kenn eine Lerntherapeutin, die schafft es auch noch, den völlig verzweifelnden Kindern, die früher in die Sonderschule abgeschoben worden sind, die den Anschluss an den normalen Unterricht bringen, indem sie die fehlenden, im Unterricht fehlenden, Bausteine und Methoden für das Kind richtigen Methoden beifügt. Das Problem ist, dass unsere Lehrer eben mit 20-30 Schülern zu tun haben.
Und das zu viele sind, um individuell darauf einzugehen.
Ja natürlich.
Was wäre eine gute Zahl? Schwer zu sagen oder?
Nein, die darf auch nicht zu klein sein. Also in der Projektgruppe ist gut mit 12-15 ist perfekt. Jetzt komme ich zu Hattie aus Neuseeland, der ja immer so gerne genommen wird, um zu sagen, die Klassengröße hat gar keinen Effekt. Doch hat sie, wenn man sie nutzt. Und das sagt Hattie auch, das wird aber dann nicht dazu gesagt. Das ist doch klar, wenn ich mit 12 oder 15 Schülern genauso einen beschissenen Unterricht mache, wie wenn ich 30 drin habe, dann hat die Klassengröße keinen Effekt gehabt. Die Reduzierung der Größe. Wenn ich aber die 12-15 Schüler, die ich sitzen habe statt der 30, wenn ich das dazu nutze, um zu sagen, jetzt kann man einen ganz tollen Projektunterricht machen und ich kann das auch und ich mache das jetzt, dann habe ich durch die Klassengröße eine Veränderung gebracht. Das war aber nicht einige Bedingung.
Die Bedingung war nicht nur, die Klassengröße muss kleiner sein, sondern die Bedingung war, ich muss Projektlernen können. Da muss man als Lehrer was können. Da muss man verstehen, wie das geht. Und das finde ich eben so schade, dass das nicht als grundlegende Fähigkeit im Referendariat geübt wird. Projekte sind leider immer noch außen vor. Das hat auch mit dem Fachunterricht zu tun und mit der immer noch stoffzentrierten Verabreichung von Fachunterricht. Das gehört noch zu den Strukturen der alten Schule. Finnland hat kürzlich gesagt, wir wollen Problemorientierung als Ausgangspunkt. Die nennen das nicht Problemorientierung, sie meinen aber das gleiche, die nennen das Sachorientierung übersetzt. Da war hier ein Aufschrei in der Presse genau, die haben die Fächer abgeschafft, die machen nur noch Problemorientierung. Das kennen wir hier auch im problemorientierten naturwissenschaftlichen Unterricht in den Klassenstufen 5 und 6.
Haben wir auch schon lange. Da wird das Thema Wasser bearbeitet. Wasser ist ja kein Fach. Wasser ist ein großes Thema. Und das kann man unter biologischen, chemischen, auch mathematischen, das kann man unter allen möglichen Fachgesichtspunkten bearbeiten, was Wasser ist, auch unter gesellschaftspolitischen, was auch immer. Und solche Themen gibt es wie die Welt, weil das sind Weltthemen. Das sind Themen aus der näheren Umgebung, das sind Themen aus der Welt, die man nehmen kann, das ist Problemorientierung. Und dabei können natürlich alle Fachperspektiven dran teilnehmen. Das ist nur in unserer Struktur, in unserer Schulstruktur so schwer zu organisieren. Und deswegen ist es so eine riesige Hürde. Und dann muss man nicht nur diese Schulstruktur überwinden, wenn man diese Fächerperspektive überwinden will, sondern man muss eben auch wissen, wie es geht.
Und Finnland hat natürlich nicht nur noch Problemorientierung und alles andere ist egal und die Fächer aufgelöst, mitnichten. Sondern du brauchst, wenn du in einem Projekt arbeitest, stößt du zum Beispiel auf ein Problem, wo du sagst, jetzt habe ich nicht genügend Chemiekenntnisse, um dieses Problem weiter zu bearbeiten. Jetzt muss ich mich mal systematisch in die Chemie reinknien, und zwar so weit, bis ich wieder auf dem Stand bin, dass ich das Problem lösen kann. Ich habe so Englisch gelernt. Ich hatte kaum Englisch an der Schule, weil ich auf so einem Traditionsgymnasium war, wo man Latein hatte. Ich habe viel später, da war ich schon hier gesessen, festgestellt, dass ich ohne Englisch nicht weiterkomme. Weil die beste Literatur über Erziehungswissenschaft, Lerntheorie und alles natürlich, was mit Digitalität zu tun hat, ist auf Englisch. Und da muss ich Englisch lernen, um die zu verstehen. Das war meine Begründung. Das ist Problemorientierung wie aus dem Leben gegriffen.
Und ich kann inzwischen sehr gut Englisch und das habe ich zum Teil mache ich auch systematisches Englischlernen, jetzt bin ich bei C1, nächste Woche habe ich wieder Bildungsurlaub, da mache ich C1 Englisch systematisch. Aber ich organisiere mir den Prozess selber, aber ein sinnvoller Lernprozess ist immer im Wechsel zwischen Learning by Doing, Problemorientierung, Produkt natürlich auch, was soll eigentlich dabei rauskommen, und immer wieder Episoden, etwas systematisch zu bearbeiten, um die Fachlogik zu verstehen, mit der etwas sage ich mal so kritisch wissenschaftlich betrachtet werden soll, weil man nicht aus dem hohlen Bauch raus Fragen beantworten kann.
Ist das so ein iteratives Arbeiten, wo man immer wieder in kleineren Schritten vorangeht. Ich habe zum Beispiel deutsche Grammatik eigentlich erst in dem Moment gelernt, wo ich angefangen habe, Regelwerke für meine eigenen Fantasy-Rollenspiele zu schreiben. Das war der Incentive, wo man erst mal sagen würde, naja das eine hat ja mit dem anderen erst mal nichts zu tun, aber das war dann eben so das. Und ich fühlte mich jetzt auch eben gerade nochmal daran erinnert, haben wir ja hier auch schon verschiedene Gespräche geführt bei Forschergeist, vor allem um die Forschung, die wissenschaftliche Forschung, die ja hier auch einen wichtigen Teil der Gespräche darstellt. Und es kristallisiert sich bei vielen Forschern heraus, dass das interdisziplinäre Forschen eigentlich so nicht das einzige ist, was man machen kann, aber dass sich im zunehmenden Maße auch die Notwendigkeit abzeichnet, um überhaupt noch voranzukommen. Breit aufgestellt zu sein.
Sich teilweise entweder selber in verschiedene Bereiche einzuarbeiten, weil man die einfach nicht außer Acht lassen kann oder dann eben auch, weil es so ein unglaublich weites Feld ist, sich hier in ein Netzwerk zu begeben und sich mit anderen zusammen zu tun. Was man ja dann quasi in so einem Schulverband ohnehin hätte, weil man hat ja auch noch die anderen Kinder. Jeder hat so seine eigenen Vorlieben und möchte sich unter Umständen vielleicht auf etwas mehr spezialisieren, dieses Wissen dann wiederum zurück in die Gruppe tragen und dann hat man eben diesen Suppeeffekt. Also jeder hat andere Zutaten am Start, aber wenn man halt alles zusammenwirft, dann hat man im Idealfall eine leckere Suppe beisammen.
Ja das kann ich nur voll unterstützen. Vor allen Dingen ich gehe mal von den Bedürfnissen der Gesellschaft aus. Also Bildung ist ja nicht nur dafür da, dass man die nachwachsenden Generationen fit für den Arbeitsmarkt macht, damit sie überleben können ohne ALG II. Sondern ist ja auch damit man Menschen in der Gesellschaft hat, die die anstehenden gesellschaftlichen Probleme anpacken und lösen können. Und die sind, Stichwort Klimawandel, das ist ja ein gesellschaftliches Problem, kein naturwissenschaftliches, sind inzwischen so komplex und brutal kompliziert, dass man mit ein bisschen Fachwissen und ein bisschen Allgemeinbildung aus der Schule die Probleme nicht gelöst kriegt. Und du sprichst Teamarbeit an. Das ist zum Beispiel was, was man nur lernen kann, indem man es tut. Genauso wie kritisches Denken. Eine der 4K-Hauptkompetenzen, die man lernen muss.
Und die alle lernen müssen, nicht nur Kinder, die auf die Universität gehen wollen. Also nicht nur Oberstufe, sondern die man von Anfang an lernen kann.
Was sind denn die anderen drei Ks?
Die anderen drei Ks sind kritisches Denken, Kollaboration, Zusammenarbeit, das ist deine Teamarbeit. Weil die aus dem Englischen kommen, haben sie Collaboration. Und das vierte C oder das vierte K ist Kommunikation. Und unter Kommunikation kann man sich eben nicht nur vorstellen, die Leute müssen …
Aber da fehlt ja jetzt noch ein K. Kritisches Denken.
Kreativität hatte ich nicht gesagt. Kritisches Denken, Kreativität, Kollaboration und Kommunikation. Und Kommunikation, man kann sie alle jetzt echt einzeln dekonstruieren und ich könnte dir so viel zu jedem einzelnen sagen. Ich will dir ausnahmsweise mal was zum Kommunizieren sagen, sonst sage ich immer am liebsten was zum kritischen Denken. Kommunizieren heißt heute, die Leute müssen es lernen, mit der gesamten Welt zu kommunizieren, und zwar jeder. Wer nicht in der Lage ist, möglichst auf Englisch natürlich, weil so ist die ganze Welt erreichbar, mit der ganzen Welt mit ihm fremden Leuten zu kommunizieren. Natürlich das meiste digital, weil er nicht mit allen Leuten gleich sich face to face begegnet, dem fehlt die zweite Kulturstufe der Literacy. Ich finde, das gehört zu den grundlegenden Literacy des 21. Jahrhunderts.
Deswegen finde ich diese 4K auch so revolutionär. Man muss sich mal folgendes vorstellen, wir bringen in der Schule den Kindern bei, redet nicht mit fremden Menschen. Das bringen wir ihnen schon im Kindergarten bei. Rede nicht mit fremden Menschen. Geh nicht in den Chat, dort sind böse Männer, die wollen dich nur treffen und dann vergewaltigen. Was bringen wir ihnen da bei? Wir bringen ihnen das Grundüberleben in der Wilderness bei. Aber eigentlich haben wir ihnen damit nicht beigebracht, wie sie doch lernen, mit fremden Menschen zu reden. Worauf sie dabei achten müssen, unter welchen Bedingungen, wie sie erkennen, dass die fremden Menschen im Netz für sie gut sind. Weil das Experten sind, die prima auf ihre Fragen antworten können. Also ich will das Wort Medienkompetenz ehrlich gesagt nicht in den Mund nehmen, weil mir das auch nicht so passt.
Sondern ich meine, dass man sich viel genauer darüber klar werden muss, dass sich die Kommunikation, nicht nur die Kommunikationsbedingungen und Geräte verändert haben, sondern auch die Kommunikationsweisen. Wir haben vorhin mal drüber geredet, dass wir uns beide nicht gerne anrufen lassen. Früher war anrufen normal. Weil es gab nichts anderes. Sonst hätte man mit der gelben Post schreiben müssen, da wäre es erst vier Tage später da gewesen, bis die Antwort da gewesen ist, hätte sich das Problem schon von selbst erledigt. Telefonieren war genial, als das Telefon aufkam. Warum wollen wir nicht mehr telefonieren? Weil wir eine andere Kultur angenommen haben. Weil sich da was verändert hat. Und auch die Frage, ich habe neulich am Flughafen erlebt. Ich war in Zürich am Flughafen, da kam eine Frau mit einem Klemmbrett im Businesskostüm und hat alle gefragt, mit Klemmbrett in der Hand, ganz wichtig Brille und so.
Und hat alle gefragt, sind Sie geschäftlich oder privat? Alle haben brav geantwortet. Nur ich habe gesagt, das geht Sie einen Scheiß an. Und die anderen haben einen riesigen Zettel an Fragen beantwortet. Ich konnte alles mithören, in the open, das war an dem Gate, es war in der Öffentlichkeit, wusste ich, der Mann mit Glatze besucht seine Freundin in Hamburg und die kennt er erst seit so und so lang. So verhalten sich die Menschen, das ist Höflichkeit, weil sie gefragt worden sind von einer Frau in Businesskostüm mit Klemmbrett. Das sind die Gleichen, die sich weigern würden, auf Facebook zu sein, weil doch da ihre Daten erhoben werden. Und verstehst du, was ich meine? Und was sicher nicht richtig ist, wenn wir den Schülern beibringen, die Medien sind gefährlich und ihr müsst sie kritisch beachten, das ist Medienpädagogik, immer diese kritische Medienbeachtung. Nein wir müssen ihnen beibringen, wie sie das Beste aus den Medien für sich rausholen.
Und unter welchen Bedingungen sie es kriegen. Unter welchen Bedingungen kann ich mir das Beste von der Gesamtexpertise der gesamten Welt holen, wenn ich eine bestimmte Fragestellung habe. Und das können auch schon Grundschüler. Ich habe einen Referendar gehabt, der hat bei mir Weblog gelernt. Und der hat Sachunterricht mit seinen Schülern gemacht, 4. Klasse, Wald. Der ist mit denen in den Wald gegangen, ganz richtig physisch und da war gerade dieser Oktober mit der wahnsinnigen Pilzrevolution würde ich mal sagen. Wir haben alle gedacht, das wäre von Tschernobyl oder was, die Pilze schossen hier aus dem Boden. Es war halt ein total verregneter Sommer, wie in Hamburg üblich. Jedenfalls war total die Pilzsaison und die Kinder hatten nur Blick für die Pilze. Da hat der Lehrer gesagt, okay, der Wald ist der Wald, heute sind der Wald die Pilze für die Kinder und die Kinder haben ein Weblog über Pilze gemacht.
Die haben Pilze fotografiert, die haben Pilze gekocht mit ihren Eltern, die haben Pilze aussortiert nach Pilzführern, haben gelernt, dass man giftige Pilze nicht nur nicht mit nach Hause nehmen darf, sondern dass man die ungiftigen, auf denen die gelegen haben, dann auch nicht mehr essen kann und so weiter. Die haben so viel mit so viel Spaß über Pilze gelernt und das alles in dem Weblog verwurstet. So viel sie schreiben konnten als Viertklässler, haben sie darin geschrieben. Und der Lehrer hat gelernt von mir, dass man ein bisschen das Netz amüsieren muss und zum Schwingen bringen muss. Und der hat im Netz Werbung gemacht für dieses Blog. Unter anderem hat sich auch die Pilzgesellschaft, ich habe vergessen, wie der wissenschaftliche Name ist, irgendwelche alten Herren, die sich mit Pilzen wissenschaftlich beschäftigen. Hat auf dieses Weblog gefunden und hat den Schülern einen Besuch angeboten. Da durften die Schüler also zu diesen Pilzwissenschaftlern zu Besuch kommen und was glaubst du, was das für ein Hallo war.
Das ist für mich die Öffnung des Klassenraums. Und die Kinder haben da mit fremden Leuten gesprochen. Mit fremden alten Säcken, die über Pilze was wussten. Aber die wussten eben am meisten über Pilze. Das waren die echten Experten. Wenn man sich das Ganze jetzt noch in einer fremden Sprache digital in Skype über alle Ländergrenzen hinweg. Man das brauchen wir doch. Wir müssen doch unsere globalen Probleme global lösen. Wenn die Kinder nur lernen, dass sie nur mit dem Nachbarn reden dürfen und mit der Freundin und mit der Mutter des Freundes, wie sollen die denn dann mit Syrien und mit Kanada und mit Indien ins Gespräch kommen und gemeinsam über die Wasserprobleme nachdenken? Oder Klimaprobleme oder über was weiß ich, das fällt mir immer ein, weil es mir so am Herzen liegt.
Mykologen sind das übrigens, die sich mit den Pilzen rumschlagen.
Wie schön, dass wir das Netz haben und du alles nachgucken kannst.
Ja ich komme immer total intelligent rüber, dabei habe ich nur gelernt, das Netz zu benutzen.
Ja.
Das ist natürlich auch eine Form der Kompetenz, die man sich sozusagen erlangen kann. Dieses, ich muss nicht unbedingt alles wissen, aber ich muss wissen, wie ich an diese Information herankommen kann, wenn ich sie brauche. Das hat ja so einen etwas humorigen Unterton, aber ich finde, da steckt schon eine ganze Menge Wahrheit drin, weil man muss ja sich nicht unbedingt selbst immer so als unendlicher Datenspeicher verstehen. Weil erstens ist man das ohnehin nicht und zweitens ist ja das auch sehr ermüdend, sich einfach nur irgendwelche Fakten reinzuschauen, ohne zu wissen, was hat das für mich für eine Relevanz. Wenn ich mich aber sehr viel mehr auf die Methodiken konzentriere, um so eine Informationen im Zweifelsfall zu gewinnen, zu überprüfen, zu verifizieren, also solche Fertigkeiten mir anlange, dann bin ich ja auch im Prinzip komplett themenoffen. Also ich kann im Prinzip mich in alles noch reinsteigern, wenn dann eben die Relevanz für mich dann auch gegeben ist.
Wenn ich das gelernt habe, dass ich im Prinzip alles lernen kann und weiß, wie ich das machen würde, um es zu lernen, dann sind wir da angekommen, wo wir eigentlich die Schüler haben müssen, wenn sie Abitur machen.
Also eigentlich gar nicht Dinge lernen, sondern Lernen lernen?
Ja natürlich, lernen, wie ich mir das Wissen aneignen kann, was ich brauche. Und wir unterscheiden ja, übrigens ist das eine wichtige Sache, die die Informatik reingebracht hat, die aber natürlich die Wissenssoziologie und die Epistomologie der Philosophie, die sich auch mit dem Begriff Wissen beschäftigt, alle übernommen haben, die auch noch nicht in der Schule angekommen sind, nämlich die Unterscheidung zwischen Dateninformationen und Wissen. Das was du eben nachgeschaut hast, nämlich dass die Pilzforscher auf Lateinisch Mykologen heißen, das ist kein Wissen, sondern das ist eine Information. Und dahinter stecken auch Daten über Latein oder was weiß ich. Also Daten sind an sich genommen, weißt du selber, nichts. Die Frage ist, wie organisiert man die Daten, dann erst kriegen sie Bedeutung. Und dann erst werden Informationen draus und diese Informationen kann man nachschauen.
Wir schauen selten Daten nach. Wir schauen meistens Informationen nach. Die Informationen sind zwar an Wissen drangeklebt, an fremdem Wissen, aber wenn wir nicht fremdes Wissen mit übernehmen wollen, also kritisch denken heißt, dass wir die Informationen, die ausgewählt werden, das hat ja schon eine bestimmte Richtung, wenn ich Informationen auswähle, die ich dann darstelle und in dieser Form kriegen wir die Informationen verpackt in Google-Suchergebnissen, zum Beispiel jeder Wikipedia-Artikel organisiert Informationen zu Wissen. Das ist das Wissen, was der Autor organisiert hat. In Wikipedia hat man noch versucht, da möglichst schön zu standardisieren, damit es leicht überprüfbar ist. Ich muss mir aber mein eigenes Wissen machen.
Und da kommt Bedeutung dazu. Also Daten werden erst im Kontext was, kriegen die erst Bedeutung und werden zu Informationen. Wenn ich die Informationen mit meinen eigenen Bedeutungen beklebe sozusagen, dann kann ich draus Wissen machen. Dann suche ich nämlich nach meinen Fragestellungen aus, welche Informationen gehören dazu, welche nicht? Das ist ja schon mal eine Unterscheidung. Welche Information halte ich für relevant, welche nicht? Und daraus mache ich mein eigenes Wissen. Und dann kann ich mein Essay schreiben und kann sagen, ich sehe dieses Problem so und so. Und dafür habe ich diese und jene Begründung und diese Informationen stützen meine Begründungen und dann habe ich mich noch mit Informationen beschäftigt, die die Begründungen nicht stützen, die sind aber wertlos die Informationen, weil und so und dann kann ich mein eigenes Wissen. Und dann erst habe ich Wissen.
Und dadurch wird auch deutlich, dass der moderne Wissensbegriff den haben wir erst seit der Digitalität. Der ist in der Zeit der Kybernetik mit entstanden, also zweite Hälfte des 20. Jahrhunderts. Das Wissen nicht eine objektive Größe ist, die auf dem Tisch liegt und die wir von da nach da transportieren können, sondern dass Wissen sich jeder aus den Informationen, die er strukturiert, selber organisiert und selber schafft. Und dann gibt es die Radikalkonstruktivisten, ich nenne sie auch Subjektivisten, die sagen, also jeder macht sich seine Welt selber und es ist alles beliebig, das ist Crap meiner Meinung nach. Das muss standhalten, was ich mir da über die Welt denke. Und the proof of the Pudding ist, passt es, kommen die Ergebnisse in der Praxis bei raus, wenn ich es anwenden will dieses Wissen und ist es in Übereinstimmung mit der …
… Prophezeiung.
Nein du mit deiner Prophezeiung. Ist in Übereinstimmung mit dem, was die Wissenschaftler beizutragen haben.
Also die wissenschaftliche Methode ist nicht obsolet, sondern ein Teil dessen.
Nein absolut nicht.
Ja die Digitalität, was hat denn das Aufkommen der Netze und das Aufkommen moderner Kommunikationsformen bereits ausgelöst in der Schule und was hätte es denn noch alles auslösen müssen?
Bereits ausgelöst hat es eine Menge interessanter Erscheinungen. Vor 15-20 Jahren kamen die Schulen ans Netz. Da hatten wir schon dreimal unsere Computerräume mit neuen Geräten versehen, die alle vor sich hinschimmelten. Und wir haben immer die neuen Generationen dann gekriegt und eigentlich wurde es wenig benutzt. Die Schüler haben Office Programm dran gelernt. Wenn es gut ging, haben sie ein Office Programm dran gelernt. Du weißt, was man mit Excel alles machen kann. Also das waren dann die höheren Weihen, vielleicht im Informatikunterricht, der immer noch freiwillig ist.
Obwohl das ist ja dann eher so ein bisschen Bürosklaventätigkeit, die man da lernt und nicht im eigentlichen Sinne Informatik.
Aber darüber kommen die Sachen in die Schule. Die gehen diesen Weg und offensichtlich wird keine Stufe ausgelassen. Jedenfalls kamen die Schulen dann ans Netz. Das wurde auch nicht benutzt. Weil einfach nur dadurch, dass du die Technik reinlieferst oder das Netz, das ergibt keinen neuen Unterricht. Und ich habe mich damals ausmären dürfen an der Schule, weil ich den Computerraum praktisch dauerbesetzen konnte und eigentlich fast mit jedem Kurs einen Großteil der Zeit im Computerraum verbracht habe.
Egal welches Thema?
Damals gab es ja noch keine Mobiles. Ja alles was sich da bearbeiten ließ. Sogar musizieren. Ich habe Keyboards angeschafft. Das waren die ersten Midi-Keyboards, die man mit Computer zusammenstecken konnte. Das war nach der Synthesizer-Ära und dann haben die Schüler mit Begeisterung komponiert im Computerraum. Und die Kompositionen konnte man sehen und gleich hören und die haben nicht mit Noten komponiert, sondern nach Gehör. Das war sehr spannend. Aber das ist alles veralteter Crab inzwischen. Und dann wurden die Netze gesperrt. Nachdem die Netze erst offen waren, wurden sie plötzlich gesperrt. Dann gab es so was wie MasterEye.
Also gesperrt von innen nach außen, gefiltert und Dinge gesperrt.
Genau, und auch heute noch. Und ich glaube, das ist noch gar nicht so lange her, haben wir tatsächlich eine – ich nenne es immer – Verhüterli-Software, eine Sperre am Server in der Schule, müssen wir haben, ist verordnet.
Wegen Jugendschutz?
Ja. Und was wird da geschützt? Man kann nichts runterladen. Da werden natürlich vor allen Dingen die Computer und die Server und das Netz der Schule geschützt, damit keine Viren reinkommen. So wie jede IT-Abteilung eigentlich Kommunikation am liebsten komplett verbietet, weil das die beste IT-Lösung ist für IT-Systeme.
Ja auch nicht ganz von der Hand zu weisen, dass das Bedrohungspotenzial da ist.
Ich mach das mal ein bisschen krass.
Aber ist schon ein Unterschied, ob man sich von außen vor etwas beschützt oder von innen die Kommunikation nach außen unterbindet oder die Recherche.
Ja, so jetzt musst du aber eigentlich das System hacken, wenn du mit Schülern ein Weblog machen möchtest. Ich habe mir dann einfach immer welche gesucht, die mir geholfen haben, das System entweder zu umgehen, indem wir meinetwegen fünf iPhones hatten und haben davon Hotspots aufgemacht. Und dann haben die Schüler eben ihr Weblog da eingerichtet. Oder du musst dann dein Weblog in die Whitelist eintragen lassen. Weil sonst grundsätzlich, alles was SocialMedia ist vom System gesperrt ist. Da kommt dann eine Seite, ups das wolltest du eigentlich nicht, du hast eigentlich was anderes gesucht. Das ist so richtig schön ein Ausdruck des bevormundenden Charakters der Schule. Das wollten wir aber nicht, nein du wolltest die Seite gar nicht haben, denn die tut dir nicht gut.
Wir beschützen dich jetzt.
Ja genau. Und natürlich, wen die dann an ihren Weblogs arbeiten, müssen sie ja auch was hochladen dürfen. Und das dürfen sie eben auch nicht. Das verhindert das Netz auch. Also du musst eine Menge Hürden überwinden und auch eine Menge Ahnung haben, wie du das machst, damit du mit den Sachen überhaupt arbeiten kannst. Und ich verstehe es nicht. Also ich verstehe nicht, warum das so sein muss.
Naja es ist so ein bisschen die Konzentration auf die Angstseite. Also man hat ja immer diese Abwägung zwischen Chancen und Risiken, also nicht alles ist toll im Internet, aber schon eine ganze Menge. Und es ist immer die Frage, richte ich meinen Blick jetzt eben eher auf das was damit möglich ist oder auf das was unter Umständen vielleicht in irgendeiner Form bedrohlich oder gefährdend sein könnte.
Die Frage ist aber, was steckt dahinter, wenn der Lehrer Angst haben muss, dass die Schüler all das Schlechte aus dem Netz rausholen oder abkriegen oder das Schlimme machen mit dem Netz, wenn sie nicht ständig beobachtet werden. Es gab so eine Software, die hieß MasterEye, da konnte der Lehrer von seinem Arbeitsplatz aus genau gucken, was die Schüler auf ihren Rechnern hatten und dies dann blockieren, um den Schülern seine Seite davor zu setzen. Das ist so typisch, diese bevormundende, du musst lernen was ich dir zum fressen vorlege, auch am Computer und darfst nur ja nicht auf eine andere Seite gehen. Und diese Vorstellung, dass er da aus dem Computer raus erschossen wird oder dass der Computer explodiert oder das Netz plötzlich kaputt geht, weil der Schüler auf einer falschen Seite war oder so, das ist ja eigentlich nur vorgelagert dem, dass der Lehrer – und das System macht die Lehrer so, dass sie so denken in der Regel – denkt, er muss immer und überall die Kontrolle drüber haben, was die Schüler tun.
Dabei erkennt der zum ersten Mal, dass er die Kontrolle gar nicht hat. Weil das Netz ihm die nämlich wegnimmt.
Ich glaube, das ist auch so ein Grundproblem oder, was die Lehrer damit haben.?
Genau. Und deswegen wird hier versucht, das generell zu lösen. Damals mit MasterEye war ja echt schräg. Ich weiß nicht, ob das noch benutzt wird. Jetzt wird das sozusagen am Server versucht, zu klären. Aber was man dabei eigentlich sich klarmachen könnte ist, hat der Lehrer denn jemals die Kontrolle über die Köpfe gehabt? Habe ich denn mit meinem Unterricht, wenn ich die Schüler mit was vollschwätze oder ihnen mit Arbeitsbögen und Lehrbüchern irgendwas zum Basteln und Denken und Zusammenstellen aufgebe, habe ich dann Kontrolle darüber, was in seinem Kopf vor sich geht? Nein habe ich nicht. Und das müssen wir lernen, das ist das Problem, dass wir die Kontrolle über Lernprozesse nicht hatten, niemals hatten. Und dass wir das deswegen getrost einfach mal hinnehmen können, dass es sowieso schon immer so war, also können wir entspannen. Und ich …
Auch so lustig, ich habe gerade einfach mal nach MasterEye gesucht.
Hast du es gefunden, gibt es das noch?
Ja schon irgendwie einen Nachfolger. Aber wenn man mal so durch die Suchergebnisse durchgeht, dann kommt dann halt, MasterEye abschalten, Sinn und Unsinn, wie ausschalten, umgehen, Forumseintrag so umgehen. Das ist sozusagen Bogus.
Ja, eigentlich ist es sozusagen der heimliche Lehrplan. Die Schüler lernen …
… Hacking.
Hat auch was für sich.
Ja, aber es ist natürlich…
Ja okay.
Aber manche sind davon dann auch wirklich abgeschreckt und dann ist das auch nichts.
Das ist ja dann wirklich die Kontrolle über den Lernprozess verloren. Und alle diese Bypässe, die man dabei organisiert, die verändern an dem Kontrollproblem ja nichts. Und Kontrolle ist ja eigentlich im Lernprozess nicht Kontrolle über die Gedanken, also über die Gedanken, die die Schüler haben. Die kann ich nicht kontrollieren und ich will ich auch nicht kontrollieren. Ich bin doch nicht in einem Polizeistaat oder in 1984. Also jetzt diese Literatur oder so. Ich will die Schüler doch anleiten, vernünftig denken zu lernen. Und da müssen sie doch ihre eigenen Gedanken haben. Und ich möchte, dass sie die authentisch zum Ausdruck bringen dürfen, damit man mit ihren Beiträgen weiter lernen kann. Wenn die aber lernen, und das tun sie ja im heimlichen Lehrplan, dass sie bestimmte Gedanken nicht äußern dürfen, weil sie damit den Lehrer offenbar ärgern oder was sagen, was falsch ist oder was nicht erlaubt ist.
Es gibt solche Sachen, vor allem im Geschichtsunterricht. Dann habe ich jede Möglichkeit verkackt, den Schülern irgendwie was vernünftiges beizubringen, weil ich gar nicht den Anschluss an ihre Gedankenwelt kriege. Und weil das schon immer stattfindet, dass die Schüler zweigleisig denken. Ein Schüler aus Afghanistan hat mir vor vielen Jahren, als ich mal Nahostkonflikt unterrichtet habe im Politikunterricht, hat er mir gesagt, ich will Ihnen mal was sagen, nur damit Sie Bescheid wissen. Wir Schüler wir sagen Ihnen gerne, dass die Hamas eine Terrororganisation ist, das schreiben wir Ihnen auch gerne in der Klausur, aber in Wirklichkeit wissen wir, dass ist eine Befreiungsorganisation, das wissen wir von zu Hause und da können Sie gar nicht gegen anstinken. Der war so ehrlich und der mochte mich auch, deswegen hat er mir sozusagen hintenrum gesteckt, dass mein Unterricht nicht funktioniert. Ich kam an bestimmte Schüler gar nicht ran.
Weil die vorne mit ihrer Maske meine Begriffe abgenickt haben, und hinten in ihrem eigentlichen echten Gehirn haben die gesagt, red du nur Alte da vorne, ich weiß es besser, weil mein Vater zu Hause hat mir das besser beigebracht. Und das ist was, womit jeder Lehrer konfrontiert ist und womit Lehrer sich – im Matheunterricht ist es vielleicht nicht so auffällig – aber sich klarmachen muss, dass er nicht kontrollieren kann, was in den Köpfen ist und dass das auch nicht seine Aufgabe ist. Sondern dass er die Schüler dazu bringen muss, dass sie authentisch sich äußern, damit das Gespräch möglichst vielfältig und authentisch ist, was den Unterricht eigentlich trägt. Also ich meine mit Gespräch jetzt tatsächlich eine Art von Dialog über die Sache.
Auch Ängste lösen oder?
Ja natürlich.
Einfach eine Vertrauensebene herzustellen, die dann vielleicht solche Konflikte dann auch auflösen kann.
Ganz genau. Naja das Problem, ist die Hamas eine Terror- oder eine Befreiungsorganisation, das hätte den Unterrichtsgegenstand voll auf den Tisch gebracht. Das wäre eine tolle Lerngelegenheit gewesen. Aber die Schüler haben sich natürlich nicht getraut, mir das zu sagen. Nur der eine, der es mir hintenrum gesteckt hat. Und das sind Unterrichtssituationen, die fordern den Lehrer aber hallo heraus. Und da kann man mit Arbeitsblättern und vorgefertigten Unterrichtsorganisationen in Häppchen eigentlich nichts mehr werden. Da muss man irgendwie anders aufgestellt sein.
Aber ich glaube, viele Lehrer sind halt nicht so aufgestellt. Also diese Angst vor dem Kontrollverlust, das ist auch so eine Angst so, ob die nun begründet sein mag oder nicht, sie ist offensichtlich da, weil es ja dem widerspricht, wie das System sich bisher so sortiert hat und was einem so gesagt wurde, wie man sich so einzurichten hätte. Und jetzt wird ja viel von dem in Frage gestellt, durch den technologischen Verlauf an sich schon. Stellt sich natürlich jetzt die Frage, wie geht das jetzt weiter? Also was sind denn jetzt die unmittelbaren Herausforderungen jetzt und wie lässt sich das gerade im Hinblick auf die technologische Weiterentwicklung so aufstellen, dass man aus dem bestehenden System heraus auch realistische Schritte angreifen kann? Also wir können natürlich viel über eine theoretische Welt philosophieren, wie es eigentlich sein sollte, entscheidend ist ja, lässt sich da so ein Pfad ausrichten, der uns von der Ist-Situation in so einen Soll-Wert bringt, an dem die Dinge etwas weniger beklaglich sind?
Ja natürlich entwickelt sich was weiter. Und da sind viele Kollegen daran beteiligt, viel mehr als 2005. Als  ich da so einsam stand. Es gab auch schon andere Einsame. Aber inzwischen, 2005 kannte man sich, zwischen 2005 und 2010 kannten sich alle. Und inzwischen sind es zum Glück so viele, dass wir uns nicht mehr alle kennen, das ist ein gutes Zeichen.
Ja, das ist schon eine richtige Community geworden auch. Gibt es da irgendeinen guten Sammelbegriff?
Ja ist noch nicht mal eine einheitliche Community, sondern was ja jetzt genau passiert und was auch richtig ist, jetzt differenziert sich das aus, es gibt verschiedene Richtungen. Es gibt unterschiedliche Herangehensweisen und unterschiedliche Konzepte und so weiter, die jetzt miteinander verhandelt werden. Also es differenziert sich aus und es ist nicht, wir sind die Netznerds und die anderen sind alles die alten Lehrer, und immer mehr Leute beteiligen sich und die Angstschwelle wird auch immer geringer. Und die Lehrer werden doch auch jünger. Also inzwischen sind ja schon wieder zwei Lehrergenerationen durch. Ich merk das auch an meinen Referendaren, wie ich mit denen arbeiten kann. Die kommen anders aufgestellt an. Ich habe ja in der Vormobilezeit schon gearbeitet, da waren nicht nur die Probleme andere, sondern da waren auch die Kenntnisse und Bedingungen anders, ans Netz ranzukommen.
Jetzt haben wir hier in Hamburg einige Schulen mit Bring your own device. Ich weiß nicht genau, was die machen. Die erste Station ist immer, dass sie den alten Unterricht mit neuen Devices machen. Das gefällt mir natürlich nicht so. Weil ich denke, es gibt auch schon besseren Unterricht als den alten Unterricht, macht es doch gleich mit Projektdidaktik, ich will das zusammenführen. Ich finde auch, das gehört zusammen. Weil das Netz, statt Hierarchie ist sie eine Ansage dank Tim Berners-Lee ist das so. Und es hätte auch anders werden können. Um mal wieder zu sagen, was hätte, wenn die Geschichte anders gelaufen wäre und das Netz beim Militär geblieben wäre. Ich glaube, man könnte das beschleunigen, und zwar indem man von oben die Bedingungen kennt, die nur von oben zu geben sind. Das habe ich vorhin schon angedeutet.
Man könnte die Geschwindigkeit, in der Deutschland seine Aufholarbeit in der digitalen Bildung macht, beschleunigen, indem man die Arbeitszeit verändert, die Lehrerarbeitszeit, in Richtung Finnland, wie ich gesagt habe. Dass die Lehrer mehr Zeit zur Zusammenarbeit haben, dass ihnen die aber auch abverlangt wird. Dass sie zusammenarbeiten mit dem Ziel, digitale Medien in ihrem Unterricht zu etablieren und dadurch den Unterricht zu verwandeln. Und dazu einen Austausch zu haben, einen generellen Austausch. Und für diese Zeit des sich Austauschens der Lehrer, die an diesem Projekt beteiligt sind, das muss Arbeitszeit sein. Das kann doch nicht ihre Freizeit sein. Das ist was, was oben bringen muss. Und von unten müssen auch Bereitschaften gebracht werden. Zur Kompetenz gehört Bereitschaft. Also Können, Wissen als Kompetenz gibt es nur, wenn man nicht nur totes Wissen im Kopf hat, sondern wenn man auch die Bereitschaft hat es anzuwenden.
Auch wenn es weh tut oder wenn es schwierig ist oder whatever. Die müssen die Bereitschaft haben, in einen Experimentiermodus zu wechseln. Und das ist ein Switch auch im Kopf. Habe ich ja vorhin schon erzählt, dass Schule eigentlich nicht gerne experimentiert. Das System Schule möchte bewerte Sachen immer wiederholen und sich ständig reproduzieren. Hast du dich schon mal gefragt, warum die 200 Jahre alte Schule eigentlich genauso aussieht fast wie vor 200 Jahren, obwohl inzwischen acht Menschengenerationen gestorben sind? Und Lehrerkollegien hundert mal ausgewechselt wurden insgesamt, und trotzdem bleibt die Schule wie sie ist?
Na klar, weil sie schon von Anfang an perfekt designed wurde.
Naja, weil das System sich nicht ändern, bloß weil die Personen das wollen, die unten arbeiten. DAs System ändert sich erst, wenn die Entscheider in diesem System andere Entscheidungen treffen. Also wirklich müssen die, die oben sitzen, also in der Administration, es gibt ja viele Hierarchiestufen, Bildungspolitik, dann die Schuladministration, runter runter bis zum Schulleiter, die müssen andere Entscheidung treffen. Und eine dieser wichtigen anderen Entscheidungen heißt, reduziert die Unterrichtsverpflichtung der Lehrer und die Zeit, die sie dann gewinnen, müssen sie einsetzen in Experimente mit neuen Medien in ihrem Unterricht. Und da dürfen sie auch mal, die müssen nicht alle gelingen, das ist ja der Witz am Experiment. Ein Experiment ist nur dann ein Experiment, wenn man nicht weiß, was bei rauskommt.
Also eigene Experimente machen, Konzepte auszuprobieren, vielleicht sogar selber Konzepte entwickeln. Im Moment entwickeln viele Lehrer eigene Konzepte, weil es zu wenige gibt. Und dafür braucht es Zeit, dafür braucht es Anerkennung und eben von oben auch den Wunsch, dass das so gemacht wird. Die Lehrer das kann nicht so bleiben wie es ist, dass die Lehrer sich sozusagen gegen das System anstrengen müssen und heimlich was machen. Sondern die müssen dafür ausgezeichnet werden.
Ja die müssen eigentlich genauso behandelt werden wie die Schüler auch. So dass man sie mal fragt, was würdet ihr denn gerne lernen? Und das dann entsprechend coachen.
Genau das. Und das ist, was die oben noch nicht geliefert haben.
Immer die da oben, die machen nur Ärger.
Mhhh ja.
Jetzt natürlich auch eine weitere Debatte, die ich nochmal ansprechen wollte. Natürlich die nach einer digitalen Infrastruktur, nach Lehrmethoden. Es gibt ja auch noch andere einschränkende Faktoren, wie zum Beispiel das Copyright. Das fängt schon bei so banalen Sachen an, wie kann ich überhaupt eine Seite aus einem Buch kopieren, um sie an die Schüler zu verteilen, damit sie sich irgendwie ein Gedicht durchlesen können. Das ist ja schon immer ein Problem gewesen, das wurde dann irgendwie mit Abgaben, Pauschalabgaben, Zahlungen und so weiter versucht, einzufangen. Und jetzt haben wir natürlich zu einem Zeitpunkt, wo im Prinzip ja alles beliebig reproduzierbar ist, ganz andere Herausforderungen und es gibt so eine Bewegung der offenen Lernmittel. Also es läuft unter dem Stichwort OER, Open Educational Resources, was für eine Rolle spielt das und was ist da schon erreicht worden? Wo müsste diese Bewegung hingehen?
Ich meine, wir haben die Wikipedia, klar da ist leicht darauf zu verweisen. Aber es ist ja nicht im eigentlichen Sinne ein Lehrmittel.
Jöran Muuß-Merholz, den kennst du?
Ja.
Der ist gerade in Kapstadt, wo ja dieses Manifest „Open Educational Resources“ international gestartet wurde, ich glaube vor 10 Jahren. Und der ist ja Spezialist hier dafür. Ich kenne mich damit nicht so aus. Und zwar einfach aus dem Grund, weil das nicht mein Problem war. Ich habe wenig mit Buch gearbeitet, Lehrbuch, das was international immer Textbook heißt, heißt ja bei uns Lehrbuch, damit konnte man in Geschichte und Musik und in Politik eigentlich nicht viel anfangen. Und wenn, dann habe ich das so als Steinbruch genommen und habe mir aus dem Buch ein Schnipsel geholt und aus dem Buch ein Schnipsel und habe mir meine eigenen Arbeitsbögen zusammengeschnipselt und die habe ich kopiert und ich habe nie nach einem Urheberrecht gefragt. Es hat mich auch nie jemand gefragt. Es gibt in der Schulentwicklung und Unterrichtsentwicklung einen wichtigen Kernsatz, ohne den man nichts wird, machen, nicht erst fragen.
Weil wenn du fragst, darfst du es nicht. Und so bin ich eigentlich immer ganz gut geritten. Und natürlich muss auf der gesetzlichen Ebene eine ganze Menge geregelt werden wegen des Urheberrechts und nicht nur wegen der Bildung. Aber ich glaube, dass man das auch nicht überschätzen darf, weil eigentlich meine ich, dass das Lernen im digitalen Zeitalter nichts mehr mit Lehrbuch zu tun hat. Viele Sachen, hast du ja vorhin auch gesagt, die lernt man vernetzt. Die lernt man nicht, weil man ein Buch durcharbeitet, und zwar ein Lehrbuch, ein Lehrbuch diskutiert keine Probleme. Ein Lehrbuch macht lehrbuchartig oder in Lektionen aufbereitet sogenanntes Grundwissen. Diese freien educational resources, dieser Kampf dafür ist ja vor allen Dingen in den Ländern, wo die Lehrbücher sündhaft teuer verkauft werden, wie in den USA.
Und wo du, wenn du das Lehrbuch nicht hast, du nicht studieren kannst. Weil der Professor möchte hören, was in dem Lehrbuch steht, was er selbst geschrieben hat und er möchte das Geld für das Lehrbuch auch noch einstreichen. Das ist der Grund in den USA, warum einfache Lehrbücher in egal welchem Fach 300 Dollar kosten. Und dann brauchst du aber was. So was haben wir ja bei uns in dieser Form gar nicht. Und in der Schule gibt es sicher Fächer, die gut mit Lehrbüchern arbeiten, aber das sind nicht meine Fächer, deswegen habe ich mich darum nie gekümmert. Die OER-Bewegung beobachte ich und kenne ich. Ich finde es richtig und wichtig, dass die weiterkommt, aber ich muss ganz ehrlich sagen, ich glaube nicht, dass sie das Herz trifft. Also es geht vor allen Dingen um den freien Zugang zu Wissen und zu Informationen und den habe ich in meinen Fächern immer gehabt.
Na gut, aber das mag ja nicht überall so sein. Und gerade wenn ich mir überlege, wenn man jetzt sagt, wir wollen das projektorientierte Lernen hinbringen, wir wollen den Schülern zuhören und die sollen jetzt mal sagen, was sie interessiert und ich möchte mir jetzt in diesem Themenkomplex, den wir jetzt grundsätzlich bearbeiten, mal das rauspicken und stelle hier auch noch eine Querverbindung in eine ganz andere Disziplin mit rein. Da steht man natürlich gerade als jemand, der, das ist nicht mein Fach, Lehrer in dem Moment auf einmal agieren muss, vor der Situation, oh wo kriege ich denn jetzt anschaulich her, wo bestimmte Grundlagen vielleicht erläutert werden. Also ein Wikipedia-Artikel ist ja jetzt auch nicht immer ohne weiteres zu knacken. Also gerade wenn ich mich da in Chemie oder Mathematik rumschlage, dann hat man es mit Artikeln zu tun, die von Chemikern im Wesentlichen auch für Chemiker geschrieben sind, die so viel voraussetzen und die sagen wir mal jetzt nicht runterskalieren auf ein niedrigeres Alter, wo man einfach noch ganz anders an die Sachen rangeht.
Also.
Ich hätte gerne mal was, was mir grundlegende chemische Vorgänge leicht erklärt. Diagramme, einführende Dinge, die an der Stelle hilfreich sind.
Ich glaube, das gibt es alles im Netz. Also alles, was ich naturwissenschaftlich wissen will, finde ich im Netz. Alles … das Problem an diesen educational resources ist, dass sie didaktisch aufbereitete Materialien suchen und betreffen. Und ich bin kein Freund mehr von diesen didaktischen Aufbereitungen, die nicht von Lernenden selber gemacht wurden. Also wenn zum Beispiel ich den Schülern sage, ihr sollt oder wollt euch mit dem und dem beschäftigen, guckt doch mal, was es dazu im Netz gibt. Dann ist es wichtiger Ihnen zu zeigen, wie sie unterscheiden können, ob das was brauchbares ist oder nicht, weil es so viel ist. Als dass ich das Problem hätte, es gibt nichts. Allein in YouTube kannst du dir die ganze Chemie erklären lassen.
Du kannst dir jede Naturwissenschaft, jedes mathematische Problem kannst du dir in YouTube in unterschiedlichsten Tutorials erklären lassen. Du hast eigentlich lauter Lehrer im Netz. Es ist mir noch nicht so ganz klar, was die OER-Leute eigentlich suchen, weil ich den … Also was ich sehe ist, dass sie bearbeitete Sachen suchen. Also wie du sagst, sie suchen eine leichte Erklärung für 7.-Klässler. Das ist nach traditionellen Schulvorstellungen zugerichtetes Material, didaktisch zugerichtet. Das ist nicht was meiner Vorstellung entspricht, wie das Lernen im 21. Jahrhundert aussieht. Aber vielleicht müssen wir diese Stufe haben, das weiß ich nicht. Das kann ich nicht beurteilen. Aber es ist nicht meine Vision von dem, wie es eigentlich geht und das hat mit meinem eigenen Unterricht auch nichts zu tun.
Ja gut, da hat man jetzt auch ein bisschen das kleine Fakenews-Problem, dass, wenn ich mich jetzt über Klimawandel informieren will, natürlich das Netz auch geradezu überbordet von Chemtrailsfanatikern und Anhängern anderer Verschwörungstheorien, die schwer zu halten sind. Da muss man natürlich dann auch nochmal mit so einer zweiten Öffentlichkeit sich auch noch rumschlagen. Wie verifiziere ich, dass jetzt dieses tolle Video den Sachverhalt auch wirklich korrekt erklärt und der nicht in irgendeiner Form einen Bias hat, um absichtlich oder unabsichtlich, den ich an der Stelle nicht…
Ja, indem ich von der Sache was verstehe.
Ja gut, aber das ist ja dann …
Der Lehrer muss was von den Sachen verstehen, die er unterrichtet und das ist Basic. Also er kann nicht nichts verstehen davon. Und wenn der nicht in der Lage ist, zu unterscheiden, ob das in seinem Fachgebiet eine valide Information ist oder eine Fehlinformation, dann tut es mir leid. Dann ist er entweder nicht fachlich genügend ausgebildet oder er ist so tief in die Materie reingestürzt, dass es sowieso nicht auf der Ebene ist, wo man mit Schülern arbeiten würde. Was für uns wichtig ist, was du eben gesagt hast, ist, dass wir viel mehr Zeit damit verbringen müssen, mit den Schülern zusammen im Netz zu sein und auf Sachensuche gehen und die Sachen zu verifizieren. Und den Schülern zu helfen. Ja woran erkennt man denn eigentlich jetzt, ob das was solides ist oder was schlechtes? Es geht ja nicht nur um die Fakenews.
Das ist ja nun jetzt so ein Hype, der eigentlich immer verdeckt, dieser Begriff, dass es eigentlich drum geht, dass während man allgemeine wissenschaftliche Kriterien anwendet, um eine Sache zu beurteilen, zum Beispiel ist die in sich stimmig? Also das kann man auch mit Dingen, wo man weniger Ahnung von hat. Aber dabei baut man auch Ahnung über die Sachen auf. Also die sind ja immer an Fachinhalte gebunden. Es gibt ja keine abstrakten Texte in dem Sinne, die über nichts reden. Das ist ein verwickelter Prozess, in dem man sich Fachinhalte dadurch aneignet, dass man anfängt zu lesen und die Sachen kritisch zu befragen. Und das musst du im Grunde genommen mit jeder Netzquelle tun, wenn du dich über was informieren willst. Ob du davon schon Ahnung hast oder nicht, du musst deine eigenen Strategien haben, um das – und die müssen wissenschaftlich haltbar sein – um das beurteilen zu können.
Und das ist doch genau das, was wir den Schülern beibringen. Wenn wir ihnen die Sachen aus dem Netz rausschneiden und sagen, nimm das, das ist gut, alles andere lass weg, geh nicht selber ins Netz, ich gebe dir was du brauchst, das ist die Ressource, mit der du arbeitest, dann können sie es ja nicht lernen. Weil dann bin ich als Autorität davor, der ihnen die Sachen schon vorsortiert hat. Was ich aber gemacht habe in meinen beiden großen Projekterprobungen mit einem Lehrer an der Stadtteilschule hier, ist, dass wir ein Weblog eingerichtet haben jeweils. Einmal für das Thema Migration-Integration und beim zweiten Mal Jahre später für das Thema Postwachstum. Also brauchen wir einen Paradigmenwechsel in unserer Ökonomie der den Wachstumsbegriff auf die Hörner nimmt.  Und da haben wir jeweils Weblogs eingerichtet, in denen unglaublich viel Material zu allen möglichen Fragen liegt.
Und dann haben wir mit den Schülern projektartig die Fragen entwickelt. Das heißt wir haben sie begleitet dabei, wenn sie ihre Fragen entwickelt haben, nachdem wir einmal anfänglich einen Start gemacht haben, wo sie mit den Problemen konfrontiert wurden und dann haben die Schüler in diesen Weblog, da kann auch jeder Lehrer jetzt mit arbeiten, weil die Weblogs ja im Netz liegen, die haben wir nicht rausgenommen, unglaublich viel Material gefunden, was sie sich aussuchen konnten, mit dem sie arbeiten wollten. Das mussten sie aussuchen danach, ob es zu ihrer Frage passt. Was wir natürlich gemacht haben ist, dass wir keinen Blödsinnsmaterial da reingestellt haben. Das wäre ja echt absichtliche Irreführung, das gehört sich nicht. Sondern wir haben unterschiedlichste Materialien, auch von unterschiedlichstem Schwierigkeitsgrad und unterschiedlichen Fragestellungen, auch von unterschiedlichen Dokumentensorten, also auch Videos und Bilder und nicht nur Texte da reingestellt, die sowieso frei im Netz waren.
Und ja dann haben die Schüler daran auch gelernt, Material passend zu ihrer Fragestellung rauszusuchen, aber es war eben nicht didaktisch bearbeitet. Es war halt der volle Spiegel-Artikel und nicht einer, in dem die drei entsprechenden Zeilen, auf die es dem Lehrer ankommt, schon rausgeschnitten sind. Und das nennt man ja didaktisch Bearbeitung, indem ich sage mal Material aus der Echtwelt zu Lernzwecken oder Lehrzwecken genommen und bearbeitet wird. Indem Texte gekürzt werden. Jede Kürzung eines Textes ist schon eine Entscheidung, die nicht nur didaktisch ist, sondern auch in politischen Fragen was politisches. Ich verändert den Kontext eines Satzes. So und dann ist der Lehrer eigentlich gewohnt, das alles auf kleine Häppchen zuzuschneiden, das muss auf einen einseitigen Arbeitsbogen passen.
Dann werden die Zeilen durchnummeriert, damit man es dem Schüler leicht macht, dass sie sagen, in Zeile 2 steht das und das, in Zeile 7 steht das und das. Das sind alles solche didaktischen Vorbereitungen. Und unten unter den Text schreibt der Lehrer dann: 1. Gib den Text mit eigenen Worten wieder. Also Arbeitsaufträge. Und das machen wir nicht. Also Max, mit dem ich zusammen arbeite, mit dem ich die beiden Unterrichtsversuche und die beiden Veröffentlichungen gemacht habe, der arbeitet wunderbar ohne dieses, mach das, mach das, mach das. Der arbeitet projektdidaktisch richtig gut, kann ich nur empfehlen, bei dem in die Schule zu gehen und sich das mal anzugucken. Der lässt ganz viel Raum für die Fragen der Schüler und leitet sie aber an, die Fragen richtig so zu formulieren, dass der Schüler damit arbeiten kann, mit dieser Frage.
Und da gehört was dazu. Denn nicht jede Frage mach Sinn. Viele Schüler sind ja gar nicht mehr in der Lage zu fragen, weil ihnen die Fragen abgewöhnt worden sind. Die Fragen stellt der Lehrer. Und ich glaube, viele kommen schon in die Schule als Schüler und haben aufgehört zu fragen, weil sie zu Hause mit ihren Fragen die Eltern so genervt haben, dass sie ständig gesagt kriegen, ach hör auf zu fragen. Und dann kommen sie und werden zum ersten Mal aufgefordert, ihre eigenen Fragen zu stellen. Und die sind dann vielleicht ein bisschen unbeholfen, sage ich mal so. Und dann müssten die Fragen erst mal umformuliert und bearbeitet werden und den Schülern muss dabei auch klar werden, warum die Frage so nicht bearbeitbar ist. Eine Frage, die man mit Ja und Nein beantworten kann, ist keine tragende Frage. Das müssen die Schüler aber erst indem sie es tun erkennen. Die Schüler müssten also viel viel mehr Projektunterricht haben, um das Fragen wieder neu zu lernen und das gescheite Fragen zu lernen.
Das haben sie nämlich verloren, die können ja nur noch antworten geben. Indem sie die Fragen des Lehrers aus den Sätzen des Lehrbuchs beantworten.
Ist halt ein bisschen so Quizshow dann.
Und übrigens die Verquizzung ist leider durch digitale Medien verführerisch angelegt. Villa Wewersbusch arbeitet mit Quizzes. Viele arbeiten nur mit Quizzes, weil das so leicht zu machen ist. Es gibt Software, da kann man schnell Quizzes aufstellen als Lehrer und die kann man den Schülern auf ihre iPads spielen und dann denkt man, man hat einen ganz tollen revolutionären Unterricht gemacht. Inzwischen hat man einen schlechteren Unterricht gemacht in Wirklichkeit, als wir schon vor 10 Jahren hatten, indem wir Schüler selbständig haben arbeiten lassen, wo es noch gar nicht bring your own device gab. Also man muss auch aufpassen, dass man sich nicht verführen lässt durch die digitalen Möglichkeiten und den Angeboten im Netz an Software und Apps.
Wieder auf einen Konditionierungsunterricht zurückzufallen. Der nur darauf geht, ist es A, B oder C? Und dann sagt, nein A war es nicht, B war es nicht, es war C, jetzt weißt du, was es ist.
Nämlich C.
Ja. Und so eine Lehre brauchen wir nicht. Also die ist schlechter, als wir es schon mal hatten.
Vielleicht so zum Ende würde mich nochmal interessieren, was für Communities haben sich denn zumindest in Deutschland, im deutschsprachigen Raum so entwickelt, die dieses Ideengut vorantreibt? Also es wird da ja eine gewisse Organisation geben, die sich jetzt nicht nur in Weblogs niederschlägt, sondern unter Umständen auch in Konferenzen oder in anderen Organisationen. Wo kann man sich denn hinorientieren, wenn man jetzt ein aufgeschlossener Lehrer ist, den dieselben Fragen schon immer gequält haben, die wir jetzt hier begonnen haben zu besprechen. Wie organisiert man sich, um das System ein wenig umkrempeln zu können?
Also die Selbstorganisation, dass Lehrer sich miteinander vernetzen, die läuft schon eine ganze Weile. Und natürlich haben sich da Organisationsformen sage ich mal so rausgebildet. Das eine ist dieser berühmte EdChat.de, den du sicher auch kennst.
EdChat.de, das ist abgekupfert sage ich mal so von dem amerikanischen EdChat.
Wie nochmal?
Also AT?
Ja Chat genau. EdChat Hashtag, das läuft über Twitter und das gab es in den USA und England und Australien. Natürlich die englischsprechenden Länder sind immer vorne und es gab zwei Kollegen, die haben das in Deutschland etabliert vor ein paar Jahren. Das ist eine Möglichkeit, die man Community nennen könnte. Also die Community gibt es ja nicht. Es gibt andere Angänge, die sind über persönliche Lernnetzwerke entstanden. Die sind also gar nicht öffentliche Communities, wo man dazukommen kann, weil die für sich werben. Ich habe eigentlich so hauptsächlich über mein persönliches Lernnetzwerk viele Kontakte. Mit den einen arbeite ich das, mit den anderen arbeite ich das. OER ist ganz gut aufgestellt. Die Konferenzen und Strukturen, die die haben, sind mir jetzt im Moment gar nicht bekannt und klar, aber da ist sicher Kristin Narr zu nennen.
Und eben auf jeden Fall Jörn Mus-Mehrholz. Die kann man einfach so googeln, da findet man alles.
Da kann man bei uns in die Shownotes gucken, da findet man das alles.
Das ist super, wenn du so was hast.
Ja. Ich hoffe, ich schaffe es, den Namen richtig aufzuschreiben.
Ja, den Jörn, wenn du ihn kennst, dann kannst du ihn auch richtig schreiben, der ist sehr speziell in der Schreibweise.
Das habe ich schon gelernt.
Und Kristin Narr sagt dir auch was?
Die schreibt sich mit K, Kristin Narr. Und dann, wer fällt mir noch ein? In der Schweiz gibt es wichtige Knoten. Manchmal sind es einzelne Personen, die eben auch wie ich mit persönlichem Netzwerk arbeiten, die aber Hubs sind eigentlich als Personen. Und das ist Philippe Wampfler aus Zürich. Ja es sind eben wie Selbstorganisation halt so läuft, ziemlich messy, also Personen, wie Netz eben sich so entfaltet. Das sind einzelne Personenknoten und dann sind Personen mit einer besonderen Beliebtheit oder Wichtigkeit. Das hat zum Glück auch häufig damit was zu tun, dass sie auch was besonderes zu bieten haben. Also nicht einfach nur, weil sie viel geliket werden, sind sie plötzlich wichtig, aber eigentlich sind sie unbrauchbar.
Die sag mir nichts, aber …
Das ist wie gesagt zum Beispiel besonders gut Philippe Wampfler und über ganz Deutschland verstreut. Ich habe so ein schlechtes Namengedächtnis, Ü60, deswegen würde ich dir gerne noch Shownotes nachliefern, um mein Personenregister aufzufüllen. Aber ich arbeite selber persönlich eben nicht mehr direkt im Unterricht, sondern bin vor allen Dingen mit Schulentwicklung und Lerntheorie und Lernentwicklung beschäftigt. Und habe vor allen Dingen Netzknoten, die auch in die Wirtschaft reichen, und zwar in alternative Wirtschaft. Also ich beschäftige mich weniger mit OER und mehr mit Commons auf der wirtschaftlichen Ebene. Und ich gucke zum Beispiel nach solchen Leuten wie Harold Jarche, der hatte deutsche Vorfahren.
Der ist in Kanada und ich finde es ganz ausgezeichnet, was er macht über die Auswirkungen der Digitalität auf die Netzwerkentwicklung, er nennt es, wir entwickeln uns zu einer Netzwerkgesellschaft, die die hierarchische Gesellschaft ablösen muss und das in der Wirtschaft. Also das ist schon unglaublich interessant. Und der hat ein Modell entwickelt für das Netzwerken zum Lernen. Weil der ist Lernberater für die Weiterbildung in der Wirtschaft und der berät auch Kommunen. Und sein interessantes Netzwerk findet man vor allen Dingen unter dem Stichwort Working and Learning Out Loud. Das finde ich allein schon, also es sagt ja schon die Bezeichnung eine ganze Menge darüber, dass Arbeiten und Lernen nicht mehr so genau auseinanderzunehmen ist.
Und dass vor allen Dingen das out loud-Lernen, dass man miteinander sprechen muss, um sich auszutauschen über das, was man da lernt, dass das eine besondere Bedeutung hat. Und wenn man das jetzt auf die Schule überträgt, vor allen Dingen wie Lehrer lernen müssen. Wir haben ja vorhin schon die Teamarbeit unter Lehrern genannt, dann würde ich das gerne in die Lehrerbildung mit reinnehmen. Also das gemeinsam den Unterricht besuchen und gemeinsam Unterricht, der gelaufen ist, hinterher am Videos auswerten oder wie auch immer. Also Praxisgemeinschaften, lernende Systeme zu entwickeln, die sich mit der Unterrichtsentwicklung beschäftigen, weil nur so kriegt man eine Veränderung hin, die mehr ist als nur an der allerletzten Stelle halt das Gerät statt eines Overheadprojektors einen Beamer genommen zu haben und das Digitalisierung dann zu nennen.
Was ist denn mit dieser Bewegung der EduCamps?
Ah die habe ich vergessen. Ja ich habe lange an den EduCamps teilgenommen. Das ist eine ganz interessante Geschichte, weil die Camps natürlich immerhin die Lehrer wieder in die Position gebracht haben, oder Educator, sind ja nicht nur Lehrer, sind ja vor allen Dingen auch ganz viele außerschulische Pädagogen dran beteiligt, in eine lernende Situation zu bringen, wo jeder Lehrer und Lerner ist und wo man die Rollen neu lernen kann. Also dass es eigentlich nicht mehr die Lehrer- und die Schülerrolle gibt, sondern alle lernen und alle lehren und durch den Austausch sind sie alle für die anderen auch gleichzeitig Lehrer. Die EduCamps laufen wunderbar. Ich weiß nicht das wievielte inzwischen. Ich habe irgendwann aufgehört. Weil das ist natürlich so, man nimmt nicht immer an der 7. Klasse immer wieder teil.
Das Problem der EduCamps ist, dass sie eigentlich immer wieder neu die gleiche Sache, dass man dort immer wieder neu die gleiche Sache lernen kann. Deshalb ist es vor allen Dingen was für die Newbies, also die neu dazukommen. Eine ganz spannende Erfahrung. Und es ist aber natürlich schwierig, weil die funktionieren nach dem Modell, jeder bietet irgendwie eine Session an und zeigt, was er beibringen könnte oder was er vorstellen könnte oder was er mit anderen diskutieren möchte. Und das ist natürlich, wenn da nicht Sachen auf Dauer sich weiterentwickeln bleibt es natürlich immer auf dem gleichen Niveau sage ich mal so. Und deswegen nehmen nicht alle teil, die vor 10 Jahren teilgenommen haben.
EduCamps sind so jedes halbe Jahr?
Zweimal im Jahr ja.
Genau. Jetzt kommt wohl das 19. demnächst.
Oh ja guck.
Tut sich was. Ja Lisa, das war ja schon ein wilder Ritt. Vielleicht so ganz zum Schluss die Frage, wie nah dran sind wir denn an der Revolution?
Wir sind mittendrin. Ich weiß nicht, was für einen Revolutionsbegriff du hast, aber weißt du wie lange die industrielle Revolution gedauert hat? Oder die Zeit zwischen der Erfindung des Buchdrucks 1400-Schieß-mich-tot von Gutenberg über die Reformation, über die Akkumulation des Kapitals, über die industrielle Revolution bis zum ausgereiften Kapitalismus, mehrere hundert Jahre. Das ist die Revolution. Die Revolution ist nicht der Sturm aufs Winterpalais. Das gibt es auch als Revolutionsbegriff natürlich, der in einer Stunde stattfindet. Wir sind mitten in dieser Transformation drin, nur sind wir halt mitten im Wald. Und weißt, wenn man mitten im Wald ist, sieht man den Wald vor lauter Bäumen nicht.
Ja okay, das heißt wir sind alle schon Revolutionäre sozusagen?
Nein das sind wir nicht. Wir sind alle in der Übergangsgesellschaft. Aber es gibt zwei Positionen. Entweder erdulden wir sie, weil wir können nichts machen, weil es gibt keine andere Gesellschaft als diese, in der wir momentan leben. Man kann zwar ein Mittelalterspiel spielen, aber in Wirklichkeit lebt man trotzdem im 21. Jahrhundert. Also die einen, die sie erdulden müssen, weil sie halt stattfindet, ob sie wollen oder nicht und die anderen, die versuchen teilzuhaben, indem sie mitmachen, und zwar so, dass sie in die Richtung geht, die sie haben wollen. Weil das ist das was wir machen können, dass wir sie mitbestimmen können, ob es in die eine oder in die andere Richtung geht. Ob es in den Plattform-Kapitalismus geht oder ob es in eine ganz neue Gesellschaftsform geht, wo die Commence regieren und wo alles open ist. Wo wir nicht nur Open Educational Resources fordern, sondern …
Generell Open Resources.
Ja auch das Wasser und der Strom und der Zugang zum Netz und der Zugang zum Essen und zum Dach überm Kopf, wenn das alles Open Access ist und ich glaube, dazu kann man das Netz benutzen, um da hinzukommen.
Schön gesagt. Dann würde ich sagen, machen wir an dieser Stelle erst mal ein Komma, ein Punkt ist das ja sicherlich noch lange nicht in dieser ganzen Debatte. Und ich bedanke mich.
Ja es war schön, dass ich mit dir reden durfte und dass du auch deine Perspektiven dazu eingebracht hast.
Ja soweit mir gute Kommentare einfallen, gebe ich sie auch gerne zum Besten. Betrifft mich natürlich auch. Ich bin auch insofern eine etwas gespaltene Persönlichkeit, als dass ich zwar zu einem Zeitpunkt durch dieses ganze Schulleben gegangen bin, was nun höchst undigital war, in den 80er Jahren. Meine eigene Realität aber schon extrem digitalisiert war und ich das sozusagen schon seit 20 Jahren den Wandel ersehne und immer noch ein bisschen im Wartehäuschen stehe, was sozusagen die eigentlichen Umstürze betrifft, aber manchmal sind halt die gefühlten Geschwindigkeiten doch anders. Teilweise ändert sich dann doch auf einmal alles sehr viel schneller, als man das selber erwartet hat und manchmal hat man vielleicht auch nur die falschen Erwartungshaltungen.
Für deine Kinder auf jeden Fall kriegst du es hin.
Das hoffe ich doch schwer.
Ja okay.
Lisa, vielen Dank.
Ja gerne.
Und vielen Dank fürs Zuhören hier bei Forschergeist. Das war es, bald geht es weiter, ich sage tschüss und bis bald.